Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishiston Plus Visa and earn three times the points at grocery stores and restaurants as well as on gas, EV charging, daily transit, streaming services, digital gaming and more all the time. Get the RBC Ion Plus Visa. Three times the points. Conditions apply. Visit rbc.com slash ion cards. Okay Martin, let's try one. Remember, big. You got it.
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》。若想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先听系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishiston Plus Visa，在杂货店、餐厅、加油站、电动汽车充电站、日常交通、流媒体服务、数字游戏等各种消费中均可赚取三倍积分。办理 RBC Ion Plus Visa，尽享三倍积分。受相关条款约束，详情请访问 rbc.com/ioncards。好了，马丁，我们来试一段。记住，情绪要饱满。没问题。
The Ford It's a Big Deal event is on. How's that? Uh, a little bigger. Ahem. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Nice. Now the offer? Lease a 2025 Escape Active all-wheel drive from 198 bi-weekly at 1.99% APR for 36 months with 27.55 down. Wow, that's like $99 a week. Yeah, it's a big deal. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Visit your Toronto area Ford store or Ford.ca today.
福特“福”利大放送（It's a Big Deal）活动火热进行中。怎么样？呃，再大声一点。啊咳。福特“福”利大放送活动。不错。那优惠呢？租赁 2025 款 Escape Active 全轮驱动版，每两周 198 起，36 个月年化利率 1.99%，首付 27.55。哇，那相当于每周 99 块钱耶。对啊，这可是大优惠。福特“福”利大放送活动。今天就光临您身边的多伦多地区福特经销店或访问 Ford.ca 了解详情。
Long had the snake lived in the dungeon, coiled in the black and filthy water, bloated from feasting on the Empress's prisoners. It was a colossal, greedy, pitiless thing, a creature of nightmares. Already it had sensed their presence, and even now it was rising for the kill. Its cruel head loomed from the shadows, its yellow eyes glittered with hatred, its fangs glistened with beads of poison, its forked tongue flickered with pleasure. Harold moved fast, groping among the corpses, scrabbling through the filth, his fingers found a broken piece of wood, but the monster was faster. Suddenly it was on him, its horrible coils winding around his chest, pulling him down
这条蛇在地牢里居住了很久，盘绕在黑暗污浊的黑水之中，因饱餐女皇的囚犯而身体肿胀。它是一个庞大、贪婪、冷酷无情的怪物，活脱脱一个噩梦般的生物。它早已察觉到了他们的存在，此刻正为了杀戮而昂起头来。它残忍的头颅从阴影中隐现，黄色的眼睛闪烁着仇恨的光芒，毒牙上挂着一颗颗毒液，分叉的信子得意地晃动着。哈罗德动作迅捷，在尸体堆中摸索，在污秽中扒找，他的手指触到了一截断木，但怪物的速度更快。突然间，它扑了过来，可怕的躯体盘绕着他的胸膛，将他往下拉
towards the water, squeezing the very last breaths from his lungs. So that was JRR Tolkien in his brilliant book Adventures in Time Fury of the Vikings chapter entitled The Return of the King. And obviously, Dominic, wasn't really JRR Tolkien, was it? It was you! It was an even better writer. It was an even better writer. Yeah.
向水面，将他肺里最后一丝气息挤压殆尽。这正是 J.R.R. 托尔金在他那本精彩绝伦的著作《时空历险记：维京人的愤怒》中，题为“王者归来”的章节。显然，多米尼克，这其实根本不是 J.R.R. 托尔金写的，对吧？是你写的！这是一个更伟大的作家写的。这是一个更伟大的作家写的。没错。
And you are describing there one of the countless thrilling scenes in the epic life of Harold Hardrada, fugitive from Norway, mercenary captain for the Grand Prince of Keeve. And now he has come to the golden city of Caesar, Constantinople, and he is a recruit in the Varangian Guard. And we will be finding out how giant serpents feature in the story later on. But for now, we are in 1035 and what is going on? So we left Harold in the last episode at the point in which he is just enlisted in the Varangian Guard, this kind of special forces unit of largely Scandinavian mercenaries. Very baggy trousers.
你刚才描述的是哈罗德·哈德拉达（Harold Hardrada）史诗般一生中无数惊心动魄的场景之一：他曾是挪威的逃犯，基辅大公的雇佣兵队长。而现在，他来到了恺撒的黄金之城——君士坦丁堡，成为了瓦兰吉卫队（Varangian Guard）的一名新兵。我们稍后会了解巨蛇是如何在这个故事中登场的。但现在，时间来到了 1035 年，到底发生了什么？我们在上一集离开哈罗德时，他刚刚入伍加入瓦兰吉卫队，这是一支主要由斯堪的纳维亚雇佣兵组成的特种部队。裤子非常肥大。
With great silk trousers, exactly. Now, no sooner has he enlisted, Tom, the news reaches the Imperial city that Arab corsairs have sailed into the Aegean, raiding the towns of the Greek islands and carrying the men, women and children off into slavery. And so for Harold Ardrada, the adventure begins. Brilliant. Very exciting. So actually, he's now going to be on campaign for the next six or seven years. Can't be sure exactly how long, but let's say roughly six or seven years.
穿着华丽的丝绸裤子，一点没错。汤姆，他刚一入伍，帝国的消息就传开了：阿拉伯海盗航行进入爱琴海，袭击了希腊群岛的城镇，并将男人们、女人们和儿童掳走沦为奴隶。于是，对哈罗德·哈德拉达而言，冒险开始了。太精彩了。非常令人兴奋。所以实际上，他接下来六七年都要一直在外征战。不能确定具体是多久，但我们姑且说是大约六七年吧。
As that Adventures in Time book, which I recommend to our listeners, describes his life is a blur of action, racing into battle on the deck of a war galley, storming ashore on an island at dawn, scaling the walls of an enemy castle, dealing out death with a sweep of his sword. Now actually the truth is we're getting most of this from the Icelandic sagas, which as we said last time, were written down at least 200 years later by people living in a different world. I mean, living in Iceland, I couldn't really be further away from Constantinople and still be in Europe. That's right. And they're also much more obviously Christian and they are doing an awful lot
正如那本我向听众推荐的《时空历险记》一书所描述的，他的一生是一片模糊的动作戏：在战舰甲板上冲向战场，黎明时分突袭岛屿的海岸，攀登敌方城堡的城墙，挥舞长剑大开杀戒。但事实上，我们的大部分信息都来自冰岛萨迦（Icelandic sagas）。正如我们上次所说，这些萨迦是由生活在另一个世界的人们在至少两00年后才写下来的。我的意思是，住在冰岛，离君士坦丁堡可以说是远得不能再远了，却依然在欧洲境内。没错。而且它们也明显带有更多的基督教色彩，并且在很大程度上
of projection. There's a lot of fictionalization, and there is a lot of use of literary formulae, which means it is very difficult for us to be certain, to have any degree of certainty about what he did. However, we have what people at the time would have called Roman sources, what we would call Byzantine sources, that give a sense of the kind of campaigns the Empire was fighting. So we can sketch out a very tentative narrative, I think. We do know that they did fight pirates in the spring of 1035. So Snorri Sturluson's saga, King Harold's saga, which is part of the cycle called Hymes Kringla, that tallies with the account of a Greek chronicler called John Skylitzes, who talks about ships from
进行了投射。其中有大量的虚构成分，并且大量使用了文学套话，这意味着我们很难确定他究竟做了什么，很难达到任何程度的确定性。不过，我们拥有当时的人们称之为罗马史料、我们称之为拜占庭史料的记录，这些记录让我们对帝国当时所经历的战役有了一个大致的了解。所以我想，我们可以勾勒出一个非常暂定的叙事。我们确实知道，他们在 1035 年春天的确与海盗交过手。因此，斯诺里·斯图鲁松（Snorri Sturluson）的萨迦《哈罗德国王萨迦》（作为被称为《海姆斯克林拉》史诗循环的一部分），与一位名叫约翰·斯基利茨（John Skylitzes）的希腊编年史家的记载相吻合，后者提到了来自北非的船只
North Africa attacking the Cyclades. So there probably was a bit of action in the Aegean. And then probably later that summer, 1035, the Varangians are sent to the far eastern borderlands of the empire, so Armenia, where the imperial army is besieging a city called Berkri on the shores of Lake Van. Now this is a world that is very kind of fragmented and confusing because the Abbasid Caliphate is largely broken up and there's all kinds of rival emirates across the Middle East, kind of Arab, Turkic, Kurdish and so on. So it's sort of all very confusing. The Roman army is besieging this city. The Vikings normally hate sieges. They're no good at them.
袭击了基克拉泽斯群岛。所以爱琴海当时可能确实发生了一些战斗。然后可能在那年夏天晚些时候，即 1035 年，瓦兰吉卫队被派往帝国的远东边境地区，也就是亚美尼亚，当时帝国军队正在凡湖畔围攻一个名叫伯克里（Berkri）的城市。这是一个非常破碎和混乱的世界，因为阿拔斯王朝（Abbasid Caliphate）已经大体分裂，中东各地存在着各种各样的敌对埃米尔国，有阿拉伯人、突厥人、库尔德人等等。所以这一切都非常混乱。罗马军队正在围攻这座城市。维京人通常讨厌围城战。他们不擅长这个。
They don't really enjoy them because they don't obviously have many towns and castles in Scandinavia, so sieges aren't really their thing. But this one goes very well. And the sagas say, oh, that's Harold. Harold's just a brilliant man and he's responsible. But in reality, the overall commander who plays a bit of a part in Harold's story was a Greek general called George Maniakes. He was another giant like Harold Hardrada. So Harold Hardrada, I think we established in the last episode, was he seven and a half feet tall? Seven and a half feet, yes. Maniakes, I'm going to read you the description by the monk and courtier Michael Psellas.
他们其实并不喜欢这样，因为他们在斯堪的纳维亚显然没有多少城镇和城堡，所以围城战并不是他们的强项。但这一次进展非常顺利。萨迦传说中说，哦，那是哈罗德。哈罗德简直是个天才，这都是他的功劳。但实际上，总指挥是一个名叫乔治·马尼亚克（George Maniakes）的希腊将领，他在哈罗德的故事中也扮演了一定角色。他也是一个像哈罗德·哈德拉达那样的巨人。那么哈罗德·哈德拉达，我想我们在上一集里确认过，他身高七英尺半？七英尺半，是的。马尼亚克，我来给你读一下修士兼朝臣迈克尔·普瑟洛斯（Michael Psellas）对他的描述。
Michael Psellas said, Maniakes was a Rothfou man, 49 feet tall and possessed of a violent temper, a fiery whirlwind with a voice of thunder and hands strong enough to make walls totter and shake gates of brass. He had the quick movement of a lion and the scowl on his face was terrible to behold. But Michael Sellers says that all basically all Verangians are, I mean, at least nine, 10 feet tall. Yeah. You sometimes you just have to trust the sources, don't you? You do.
迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说，马尼亚克是个身材魁梧的男子，身高四十九英尺，脾气暴烈，是一个声音如雷霆、双手强劲到足以让城墙摇晃、铜门震颤的烈火旋风。他有着狮子般敏捷的动作，脸上的怒容让人望而生畏。但迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说，基本上所有的瓦兰吉人都——我的意思是，至少有九到十英尺高。对。有时候你只能相信史料，对吧？确实如此。
An air of skepticism. You could carry skepticism too far. Well, there's kind of hint of Samson there, I think tall. Yeah. Sometimes you just have to trust the sources, don't you? You do. An air of skepticism. You could carry skepticism too far. Well, there's kind of hint of Samson there, I think, in his description. They're shaking the gates of brass, making walls totter, exactly. So Maniarches and Harold didn't get on at all. And the sagas say the Varangians demanded that Harold be put in command, said this Maniarches has got to go, but actually Maniarches had Harold record to Constantinople, but that worked out well for him because if this story is even remotely accurate,
带着一丝怀疑的态度。你可能会把怀疑态度推向极端。嗯，我觉得他的描述里有点参孙（Samson）的影子。对。有时候你只能相信史料，对吧？确实如此。带着一丝怀疑的态度。你可能会把怀疑态度推向极端。嗯，我觉得他的描述里有点参孙的影子，在震颤铜门、让城墙摇晃这方面，完全是这样。所以马尼亚克和哈罗德一点也合不来。萨迦说，瓦兰吉人要求让哈罗德担任指挥官，说这个马尼亚克必须走人；但实际上，马尼亚克让哈罗德返回了君士坦丁堡，不过这对他来说结果不错，因为如果这个故事哪怕有一点点准确的话，
he then got sent on a very exciting expedition. So we do know that the emperor had concluded a deal with the Fatimids in Egypt to rebuild the church of the Holy Sepulchre in Jerusalem, which had been semi-destroyed by a mad caliph in 1009. So Al-Hakim, who features in my thrilling vampire novel, The Sleeper in the Sands. Really? Yeah.
他随后就被派去执行一次非常令人兴奋的远征。我们确实知道，皇帝曾与埃及的法蒂玛王朝达成一项协议，以重建耶路撒冷的圣墓教堂（Church of the Holy Sepulchre）。这座教堂在 1009 年曾被一位疯狂的哈里发半数摧毁。也就是阿尔·哈基姆（Al-Hakim），他出现在我惊心动魄的吸血鬼小说《沙中眠者》（The Sleeper in the Sands）中。真的吗？对。
Is he a vampire? No, Al-Hakim isn't. But vampires are present. Vampires are definitely present. But also Dominic, just to say that the destruction of the Church of the Holy Sepulcher, which had been built by Constantine and was pretty, you know, I mean, it's, it's the great focus of Christian devotion. It has a massive impact, not just on Byzantium, but on Latin Christendom. And the news of it going back to Latin Christendom stirs up all kinds of millennial anxiety. So it's part of this
他是吸血鬼吗？不，阿尔·哈基姆不是。但吸血鬼确实在场。吸血鬼绝对在场。不过多米尼克，顺便说一下，圣墓教堂的被毁——这座教堂由君士坦丁大帝建造，相当……你知道的，它是基督教崇拜的伟大核心——它不仅对拜占庭，而且对拉丁基督教世界都产生了巨大的影响。这一消息传回拉丁基督教世界，激起了各种千年王国焦虑（millennial anxiety）。所以它是这种末日恐惧漩涡的一部分，从长远来看，这将助长第一次十字军东征。
kind of swirl of apocalyptic dread that in the long run will feed into the first crusade. So Urban II, when he does his great sermon kind of summoning the first crusade, he makes mention of exactly this, the destruction of the Church of the Holy Sepulcher. And it may not surprise Jewish listeners to discover who a lot of Christians in Latin Christendom blamed for this. And it wasn't Al Hakeem. Oh really? So this gives rise to a lot of pogroms and stuff. It gives rise to one of the first kind of big outbreaks of antisemitic violence in Latin Christendom. Yeah. So it really reverberates.
因此，乌尔班二世在发表召唤第一次十字军东征的伟大布道时，专门提到了这一点，即圣墓教堂的破坏。犹太听众可能会毫不惊讶地发现，拉丁基督教世界的许多人将此归咎于谁。而那并不是阿尔·哈基姆。哦，真的吗？所以这引发了许多大屠杀之类的事情。它引发了拉丁基督教世界反犹太暴力的大规模爆发之一。所以它确实产生了巨大的反响。
Right. So anyway, the emperor has concluded this deal to go and rebuild it. And he sends a team of architects and carpenters and stuff and bishops and monks and Roman bigwigs who want to go and see the church and a Varangian escort was sent with them and the sagas say Harold was one of them. Jerusalem is a bit of a building site when they get there, if he does genuinely go. It had been very badly smashed up by this mad caliph and by the Fatimids generally, but there'd also been a series of earthquakes in the 1030s. So if they got there, a lot of the stuff was in ruins. The sagas say that Harold is there as part of this escort and he, and I quote, generously
没错。总之，皇帝已经达成了重建它的协议，他派去了一支由建筑师、木匠、主教、修士以及想要去看看这座教堂的罗马大人物组成的队伍，并派了一支瓦兰吉护卫队随行，萨迦说哈罗德就是其中之一。如果他真的去了的话，他们到达时耶路撒冷有点像个工地。它被这个疯狂的哈里发以及整个法蒂玛王朝严重破坏了，但在 1030 年代还发生了一系列地震。所以如果他们到了那里，很多东西都成了废墟。萨迦说哈罗德作为这支护卫队的一部分在那里，并且他——我引用原话——“慷慨解囊，捐赠了多得无人知晓数量的黄金”。
gave donations so much gold that no one knows the amount. The sagas also say he'd left all his gold in Constantinople before he left, so those things can't both be true. And given that he's saving all this money, in his saver account, I think it's highly unlikely that he travelled with enormous quantities of gold. Snorri Sturluson in King Harald's saga says, Harald went to the Jordan and bathed in the water in the manner of all pilgrims. Might be true, mightn't it? Yeah, and there's absolutely no reason to believe that wouldn't be true.
萨迦还说他在离开前把所有的黄金都留在了君士坦丁堡，所以这两件事不可能同时为真。鉴于他一直在他的储蓄账户里攒钱，我认为他随身携带大量黄金的可能性极低。斯诺里·斯图鲁松在《哈罗德国王萨迦》中说：“哈罗德去了约旦河，像所有朝圣者一样在水中沐浴。”这可能是真的，不是吗？对，而且完全没有理由相信这不是真的。
That's exactly what he would do. But his longest posting, so probably after this was to Sicily. And this seems to have been from about 1038 to 1041. And Sicily, of course, as you will note Tom, is the, one of the great strategic prizes in the Mediterranean. And we did the series about Carthage versus Rome. Remember you were taking it through all the battles there. I mean, basically that hasn't changed at all.
这正是他会做的事。但他任职时间最长的驻地——可能是在这之后——是西西里。这似乎是从大约 1038 年持续到 1041 年。当然，正如你所注意到的，汤姆，西西里是地中海地区最重要的战略奖品之一。我们曾做过关于迦太基对阵罗马的系列节目。还记得你当时一直在讲述那里的所有战役吗？我的意思是，基本上情况一点也没有改变。
Sicily is very fertile. It's very rich. It's perfectly placed. It's been under Islamic rule for what? 140 years, something like that. The Kalbid emirs who are based in Palermo and they're the people who introduced oranges, lemons, sugar, silk silk and all sorts of exciting irrigation systems. We do love an irrigation system on the rest of history, do we not?
西西里非常肥沃。它极其富庶。它的地理位置堪称完美。它在伊斯兰统治下已经有多久了？140年，差不多吧。卡尔比德埃米尔（Kalbid emirs）以巴勒莫为基地，正是他们引入了橙子、柠檬、糖、丝绸以及各种令人兴奋的灌溉系统。我们在《历史的其余部分》中不是很喜欢灌溉系统吗？
Oh, I love it. I love it. I mean, history is basically the story of irrigation systems, isn't it? In a very real sense, yes. Yes. So the Roman army landed probably about 10,000 troops under George Maniachis, nine feet tall. Must have been very displeased to see Harold Hartrath. Yeah, I know.
哦，我太喜欢了。我超爱。我的意思是，历史基本上就是关于灌溉系统的故事，对吧？从非常现实的意义上讲，是的。是的。所以罗马军队登陆了，在乔治·马尼亚克（身高九英尺）的带领下大约有 10,000 名士兵。看到哈罗德·哈德拉达，他肯定非常不高兴。是的，我懂。
Now this is where the sagas really get stuck in. They have some great fun with all this. So to give you a sense of the sort of stories they tell, we've got bird action. So Harold gets the Varangians to collect birds. They fix bits of burning sulfur to their feet and send them out over the town. You know, they land on all the thatched roofs, the igneous have been flamed. The slight drawback with this story is that it's been told about every commander in history.
现在，这就是萨迦大显身手的地方了。它们在所有这些事情中找到了极大的乐趣。为了让你体会一下它们所讲述的故事的风格，我们来看看鸟类战术。哈罗德让瓦兰吉卫队收集鸟类。他们在鸟爪上固定燃烧的硫磺碎片，然后把它们放飞到城镇上空。你知道的，它们降落在所有的茅草屋顶上，那些茅草瞬间燃起了大火。这个故事唯一的微小缺陷是，历史上几乎每一位指挥官都被传说过这种事。
Well, but more specifically, Dominic, it's been told about St Olga. Of Kiev. Of Kiev, who's the grandmother of Vladimir. And she was the very first Kievan ruler to be baptised. Right. And she played exactly that trick, didn't she, on, I think it was the very first Kievan ruler to be baptized. Right. And she played exactly that trick, didn't she? Oh, and I think it was the Drevlians. It was, it was the Drevlians.
不过更具体地说，多米尼克，这个故事曾被用来形容基辅的圣奥尔加（St Olga）。基辅的圣奥尔加，也就是弗拉基米尔的祖母。她是最早受洗的基辅统治者。没错。她对……我想那是对德雷夫利亚人（Drevlians）用过完全相同的计谋，对吧？
So I think you can see a certain influence there, I would say. Well, hold on. You could say, therefore the story is clearly made up. This is just the old group of Kiev story. Or you could say he's been influenced because he's been in Kiev and he's picked up these important military techniques involving birds. You could say that. Then there's tunnel drama.
所以我想你可以看到其中的某种影响，我会这么说。等等。你可以说，因此这个故事显然是编造出来的。这只是基辅圣奥尔加故事的翻版。或者你可以说他受到了影响，因为他去过基辅，并学到了这些涉及鸟类的重要的军事技术。你也可以这么说。接下来是地道大剧。
So this is outside a town near Mount Etna and the sagas, which always paint maniocs with his nine feet of flesh as an absolute fool. He says, oh, this, we can never take this town. And Harold says, no, if you allow me the loot when I get in, I should show you. And he and the Varangians dig a tunnel all the way from a nearby ravine. They burst out of the tunnel into the great hall of the defenders while they're having a feast. Who would have thought it? Slaughter them all, throw up in the gates. That was good killing that day. And my favorite one is the coffin ploy.
这是在埃特纳火山附近的一个城镇外，萨迦总是把拥有九英尺身躯的马尼亚克描绘成一个绝对的傻瓜。马尼亚克说：“哦，这个，我们绝对攻不下这座城。”而哈罗德则说：“不，如果你允许我进城后掠夺财物，我向你展示怎么做。”于是他和瓦兰吉人从附近的一条峡谷一直挖了一条地道。他们在防御者正在举行宴会的时侯，从地道里突然冲进了防御者的大厅。谁能想到呢？将他们全部屠杀，打开城门。那一天杀得痛快。而我最喜欢的是棺材诡计。
Oh, this is brilliant. This is the Syracuse one. This is in Syracuse. So they can't take this town. The Romans don't know how to take this town. He says, I've got a brilliant wheeze. They spread the word. Harold is very seriously ill. Then the word spreads. He's dead. And the Varangians send messengers into the city where there are Christian churches as well as mosques. And they say, look, we'd love to give a church funeral. I know we've been besieging you, but would it be okay if we came in? And the local churchmen, very kindly people say, oh, yes, okay. As long as you, you can only bring 12 men in to bury this guy.
哦，这太精彩了。这就是锡拉库萨的那次。这发生在锡拉库萨。所以他们攻不下这座城。罗马人不知道该如何攻克这座城。他说：“我有个绝妙的主意。”他们散布消息。哈罗德病得非常重。然后消息传开：他死了。瓦兰吉人派信使进入城内——城里既有基督教堂也有清真寺——他们说：“看，我们希望能为他举行一个教堂葬礼。我知道我们一直在围攻你们，但如果我们能进去，行吗？”而当地的教堂神职人员，非常仁慈的人们说：“哦，可以，没问题。只要你们只能带12个人进去埋葬这个人。”
But Tom, it was astounding to know this is all a cunning trick. And actually Harold, Harold is not dead. He's one of the 12 pallbearers and they're all slightly implausibly wearing armor and carrying swords under their silk morning clothes and they're all 12 foot. Yeah. So at this point, actually his, his great friends in the Varangians, they're also part of the pallbearers and these are two splendid men called Ulf and Haldor. They're both from Iceland.
但是汤姆，令人震惊的是，这一切都是个狡猾的计谋。实际上哈罗德并没有死。他是12名抬棺人之一，而且他们身上都有些难以置信地穿着盔甲，在丝绸丧服下面藏着宝剑，并且他们12个人个个都有12英尺高。是的。所以在这一点上，实际上他在瓦兰吉卫队中的好朋友们，他们也是抬棺人的一部分，这两个光彩照人的家伙名叫乌尔夫（Ulf）和哈尔多（Haldor）。他们都来自冰岛。
They are described as men of exceeding strength and superb warriors. And the amazing thing is the three of them map perfectly onto Aragorn, Legolas and Gimli from the Lord of the Rings. So Ulf, we are told, a man of great understanding, clever in conversation, active and brave and with all true and sincere. So he's clearly Legolas. Whereas Haldor, very stout and strong, he was not a man of many words, but short in conversation, told his opinion bluntly and was obstinate and hard.
他们被描述为人极其强壮、堪称一流的战士。而神奇的是，他们三个与《指环王》中的阿拉贡、莱戈拉斯和吉姆利完美对应。因此，我们被告知乌尔夫是一个极具理解力、善于交谈、活跃勇敢且始终真诚的人。所以他显然是莱戈拉斯。而哈尔多则非常壮实强健，他不善言辞，说话简短，直言不讳且顽固而强硬。
So he's Gimli. Yeah, he's a dwarf. So Dominic, so they're both from Iceland. Do you think that this makes the story less or more plausible? So in other words, is Snorri Stelarson kind of making it up and making them be Iceland because he's an Icelander or is it preserving authentic memories handed down by the people of Iceland? There's no doubt in my mind that this is preserving authentic memories that have never been embellished
所以他就是吉姆利。对，他是个矮人。那么多米尼克，他们都来自冰岛。你认为这会让这个故事变得更可信还是更不可信？换句话说，斯诺里·斯图鲁松是因为自己是个冰岛人，才编造出这些情节并让他们成为冰岛人，还是说这保留了冰岛人民代代相传的真实记忆？我毫无疑问地认为，这保留了从未被修饰且一丝不苟地准确的真实记忆。
and are scrupulously accurate. So the story that follows is true. They get inside the gatehouse with this coffin and then apparently they drop the coffin, they blow a trumpet, the coffin blocks the gate. So then the rest of the army can pile in after them. There's incredibly fierce fighting. All three of them are wounded.
所以接下来发生的故事是真的。他们带着这口棺材进入了门楼，然后据传说他们扔下了棺材，吹响了号角，棺材堵住了大门。于是其余的军队就可以跟在他们身后蜂拥而入。战斗异常激烈。他们三人全都受了伤。
Harold's standard bearer is killed. And Harold says to Haldor, pick up the standard, pick up the standard. But Haldor is fighting off a dozen men at that point. And he says to his, to Harold, let the devil carry the standard for you, you coward. And Harold, do you want to do Harold's laugh? He gives a great belly laugh, doesn't he? He does. You are talkative today, Haldder, but fearless all the same.
哈罗德的旗手被杀了。哈罗德对哈尔多说：“拿起军旗，拿起军旗！”但此时的哈尔多正在与十多个人浴血奋战。他对哈罗德说：“让魔鬼替你扛旗吧，你这个懦夫。”而哈罗德——你想模仿一下哈罗德的笑声吗？他发出了爽朗的大笑，对吧？他确实笑了。你今天话挺多啊，哈尔多，不过倒也无所畏惧。
And then he smacks off another head with his axe. This is exactly what happened. I'm afraid I might have broken the microphone with that mighty laugh. Yeah, I think you've broken the sound barrier with that. So now the sagas say that as a result of all these wheezes, they managed to take Sicily and people can gauge the accuracy of the sagas by the fact that in fact, Sicily was never taken and the Romans ended up with just a pitiful foothold in the Northeast. And actually Sicily didn't, here's the irony, Sicily didn't fall till the end of the century and it fell to the Normans.
然后他挥起斧头又砍掉了一个脑袋。这绝对就是当时发生的事。恐怕我刚才那一阵大笑把麦克风给震坏了。对，我觉得你用那声笑打破了音障。现在萨迦传说中说，由于所有这些诡计，他们成功占领了西西里。人们可以从一个事实来衡量萨迦的准确性：事实上，西西里从未被攻陷，罗马人最后只在东北部得到了一个可怜的据点。而且实际上西西里并没有——这就是讽刺之处——西西里直到世纪末才陷落，而且是被诺曼人攻陷的。
Because it does fall to people of Scandinavian descent. Yeah, but not these guys. So we've been talking about this in our previous series about the Normans adventurers who've been going to the south of Italy at the beginning of the 11th century and building their castles there, employing their armor, their horses in the way, kind of predatory manner. And they start looking at Sicily. And amazingly, they launch an invasion. And there is another famous bird related story in this. So
因为它的确是被斯堪的纳维亚血统的人攻陷的。对，但不是这群家伙。所以我们在之前的关于诺曼冒险者的系列节目中讨论过这一点：他们在 11 世纪初前往意大利南部，在那里建造城堡，以一种掠夺成性的方式运用他们的盔甲和马匹。然后他们开始把目光投向西西里。令人惊奇的是，他们发动了一场入侵。这里面还有另一个著名的与鸟有关的故事。所以
in 1066, Roger de Oudveld, the great, who will become the ruler of Sicily, he defeats a Muslim army and the Muslims have brought along carrier pigeons. And Roger takes these carrier pigeons and he orders the paper that they've been carrying to be dipped in the blood of the Muslim dead, given back to the carrier pigeons, who then fly back to Palermo with news of the great Muslim defeat and the Normans then capture Palermo. Wow. So there's a lot of bird related action in this episode.
在 1066 年，日后将成为西西里统治者的伟大人物罗歇·德欧特维尔（Roger de Hauteville）击败了一支穆斯林军队，而穆斯林随身带来了信鸽。罗歇抓住了这些信鸽，并下令将穆斯林死者的鲜血涂抹在它们一直携带的纸上，然后将纸绑回信鸽身上，信鸽随后带着穆斯林惨败的消息飞回了巴勒莫，接着诺曼人便攻占了巴勒莫。哇。所以这一集里有很多与鸟相关的剧情。
People of Scandinavian descent interfering with birds for military purposes. Yes, it's the theme. So they don't take Sicily, but everyone says that Harold has done brilliantly. And when he gets back to Constantinople, he is, we are told, promoted to an elite bodyguard of the emperor. Manglovites is his name, he has a special golden sword. And then the emperor, Michael IV, who you may remember from the previous episode, was the Emperor's toy boy, who has basically strangled his predecessor to become emperor. He's going off to fight the Bulgars in 1040.
斯堪的纳维亚血统的人为了军事目的而干扰鸟类。是的，这就是主题。所以他们没有攻下西西里，但所有人都认为哈罗德表现得极为出色。当他回到君士坦丁堡时，我们被告知他被晋升为皇帝的精锐贴身卫队。他的称号是曼格洛维特（Manglovites），他拥有一把特别的金剑。然后皇帝米海尔四世（Michael IV）——你可能还记得上一集里他曾是皇帝的情夫，基本上勒死前任而当上了皇帝——他要在 1040 年去攻打保加利亚人。
And we know, we really do know that he takes Harold Hardrada with him, because serving alongside them was a soldier called Cacauamanos who later wrote a military manual and in this manual he wrote, Araltes campaigned with the emperor and performed great deeds of valor against the enemy as was fitting for one of his noble race and personal ability, Araltes Harold. And it's fascinating because that suggests that there are people in Constantinople now who are aware of Harold's noble descent.
我们知道，我们真的知道他把哈罗德·哈德拉达带上了，因为与他们并肩作战的还有一个名叫卡考马诺斯（Cecaumenos）的士兵，他后来写了一部军事手册。在这本手册中他写道：“阿拉尔特斯（Araltes）与皇帝一同出征，对敌人建立了伟大的功勋，正如他那高贵的血统和个人的能力所匹配的那样。”阿拉尔特斯就是哈罗德。这非常迷人，因为这表明君士坦丁堡现在有人意识到了哈罗德的高贵血统。
So though I think they see the manual is probably written after he's become king. So after he has spoiler alert after he's returned to Norway. Anyway they they smashed the Bulgarians. They capture the Bulgarian king, the cut off his nose, the gouged out his eyes. They let him back in chains to Constantinople. And Cacumanus says that the emperor rewarded Oraltes for his valour and gave him the title of Spathorokandidatos, which is a court rank, not a military one. So a kind of rank at court, very prestigious for any foreigner, let alone a barbarian from the wilds of the north. So he now gets an even fancier sword and he
不过我认为这本手册很可能是在他成为国王之后写的。也就是在——剧透警告——他返回挪威之后。总之，他们击溃了保加利亚人。他们俘虏了保加利亚国王，割掉了他的鼻子，挖出了他的双眼。他们把他戴着镣铐送回了君士坦丁堡。卡考马诺斯说，皇帝为了表彰阿拉尔特斯的英勇，授予他“斯帕托罗坎迪达托斯”（Spathorokandidatos）的称号，这是一种宫廷头衔，而不是军衔。所以这是一种宫廷里的头衔，对任何外国人来说都极具威望，更不用说来自北方荒野的野蛮人了。于是他现在得到了一把更华丽的剑，还有
gets a special golden torc called the Maniacion which he gets to wear. It's a bit like the Ottomans giving Nelson that massive great jewel. Yeah, and Harold's only 25 at this point. So he's clearly made a name for himself and he's done extremely well and it's all very exciting. But now this is where the sort of Game of Thrones side replaces the Lord of the Rings. So the Emperor Michael, he's Michael the fourth, he's called Michael the Paphlagonian, he's from the Black Sea coast of Anatolia. And his brother John, who was the eunuch kind of Lord Chamberlain, had got him a job at the court. He's got all his brothers a job, hasn't he? And basically all his cousins and stuff.
一条名为“马尼亚克”（Maniacion）的特制金项圈，并获准佩戴它。这有点像奥斯曼人送给纳尔逊的那颗巨大的珠宝。是的，而此时哈罗德只有 25 岁。所以他显然已经名声大噪，干得极为出色，这一切都令人兴奋极了。但接下来，事情的走向从《指环王》变成了《权力的游戏》。皇帝米海尔——他是米海尔四世，被称为帕夫拉戈尼亚的米海尔（Michael the Paphlagonian），他来自安纳托利亚的黑海海岸。他的兄弟约翰是一名太监，曾担任宫廷总管，为他在宫廷里谋得了一份差事。他给所有的兄弟都谋了差事，不是吗？基本上还有他所有的表亲之类的人。
So there's one called Anthony the Fat. He becomes the Bishop of Nicomedia, thanks to John's string pulling. And John is essentially the kind of prime minister, isn't he? He is. He's um... Little finger. Little finger or Varys. He's a eunuch, so he's Lord Varys.
所以其中有一个叫胖子安东尼（Anthony the Fat）。多亏了约翰在幕后运作，他成了尼科米迪亚（Nicomedia）的主教。而约翰基本上就是首相，对吧？是的。他是个……小指头。小指头或瓦里斯。他是个太监，所以他就是瓦里斯大人。
From Game of Thrones. So this guy, Michael, he had seduced Zoe, he'd possibly murdered her husband in his bath. He's now been emperor for six years. He's in his late twenties. Michael Sellas says he was as fresh as a blossom, bright-eyed and apple-cheeked. Nice. So that's nice. Unfortunately, Michael's good looks are starting to curdle because he's always suffered from epilepsy and it's getting much worse. And when he has fits,
来自《权力的游戏》。所以这个叫米海尔的家伙，他曾勾引过佐伊（Zoe），可能还在浴缸里谋杀了她的丈夫。他当皇帝已经六年了。他二十多岁快三十岁。迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说他“如花朵般清新，目光明亮，面颊红润”。不错。那挺不错的。不幸的是，米海尔的好样貌开始走样了，因为他一直饱受癫痫困扰，而且病情越来越重。当他发作时，
this is hidden from visitors to the court behind a series of elaborate curtains, which can be deployed at any moment. But he's now suffering from edema, dropsy, which means that his body is being grotesquely swollen with fluid. And by late 1041, it's pretty obvious that he's dying of this. There's no cure. They don't know what to do. Although I spoke, they could try and drain him, but that doesn't work. Now, John, the eunuch says to him, look, you're going to have to name a successor.
宫廷的访客们会被一排可以随时拉开的精美帷幕挡在后面，从而看不到这一幕。但现在他又患上了水肿，也就是水臌，这意味着他的身体被体液严重肿胀。到了 1041 年底，很明显他将死于此症。这无药可救。他们不知道该怎么办。虽然我说过，他们可以尝试给他放水，但那不管用。现在，太监约翰对他说：“听着，你得指定一个继承人。”
And ideally from our family, because we want to stay on top. And as luck would have it, they have another Michael, who is their sister's son. It's brilliant isn't it, how everyone is called Michael. Got loads of Michaels. Or Harold. He says, why don't you adopt this Michael. You and Zoe adopt him as your son. He'll be named Caesar and we'll put him in a townhouse in the suburbs and you know, he
理想情况下应该从我们家族中选，因为我们想稳坐大位。真走运，他们还有另一个米海尔，他是他们姐姐的儿子。每个人都叫米海尔，这不是很棒吗？有一堆米海尔。或者叫哈罗德。他说：“你为什么不收养这个米海尔呢？你和佐伊收养他作为儿子。他将被册封为凯撒，我们把他安排在市郊的一栋城市住宅里，你知道的，他
can hang around and when you die, he'll come in as Michael the fifth. So we come to the 10th of December, 1041, Michael the fourth is bloated, he's swollen, fluid everywhere, shambles. So his loving days are over. His loving days are over. He's taken to the monastery of St. Cosmas and St. Damien and there he's given holy orders.
可以在那里闲晃，等你死了，他就可以作为米海尔五世进宫登基了。”于是我们来到了 1041 年 12 月 10 日，米海尔四世身体肿胀，浑身是水，到处流淌着体液，步履蹒跚。所以他的柔情蜜意到头了。他的柔情蜜意到头了。他被带到了圣科斯马斯和圣达米安修道院，在那里他被授予了圣职。
Actually, it's not just kind of confession. He's given holy orders. He's tonsured like a monk and then he dies. Meanwhile, Michael the fifth, he's brought to the palace. It's really smooth succession. It works perfectly. So everything looks great. However, there is a twist.
其实不只是忏悔。他被授予了圣职。他被像修士一样剃度，然后他就死了。与此同时，米海尔五世被带到了宫殿。这是一个非常顺利的权力交接。它进行得完美无缺。所以一切看起来都很棒。然而，剧情来了一个反转。
So we'd mentioned only in passing Zoe. Zoe is now in her late fifties. She is the one person in the palace who has the blood of the Macedonian dynasty. I kind of imagine her as looking like Diana Dores. Yes, who would she be played by now? She's quite sort of... Blousy. I was going to say blousy. Well, I can tell you what Michael Sellers says. Zoe was well-rounded, though not very tall. She had hair of gold and her entire body
所以我们之前只是顺便提到了佐伊。佐伊此时已经五十多岁了。她是宫中唯一拥有马其顿王朝血统的人。我总觉得她的长相有点像戴安娜·多尔斯（Diana Dors）。是的，现在如果拍成电视剧，她会由谁来演呢？她相当那种……俗艳。我本来想说俗艳的。好吧，我可以告诉你迈克尔·普瑟洛斯是怎么说的：“佐伊体态圆润，虽然个子不算太高。她拥有金色的秀发，整个身体
glowed with the paleness of her skin. There was little sign of her age. In fact, if you noticed the perfect proportions of her limbs and did not know her, you would have thought she was a young woman, for her skin was unwrinkled, glossy and smooth, with no lines anywhere. I think it's fair to say Michael said this is slightly objectifying, Zoe. He is, isn't he? He's behaved poorly, he's let himself down. Or he's paying compliment to the power of the unguent merchants of Constantinople. He is, because she let us we'd established last time she loves a
都散发着她那苍白皮肤的光泽。岁月几乎没有留下痕迹。事实上，如果你注意到她四肢完美的比例却又不了解她，你可能会以为她是一个年轻女子，因为她的皮肤没有一丝皱纹，光洁平滑，哪里都没有细纹。”我觉得可以说迈克尔·普瑟洛斯对佐伊有点物化了。他确实是，对吧？他表现得很差劲，他让人失望了。或者他是在恭维君士坦丁堡药膏商人们的力量。他确实是，正如我们上次所说，她极度热爱
potion or cream. So hence wrinkle free. Wrinkle free, ointments just basically massively into ointments. She is, Michael Seller says a woman of passionate desires prepared equally for life or death. Now she had placed a bet on Michael the fourth and actually that had gone horribly wrong because once he'd, I mean you say his loving days were over when he became sworn with Dropsy, but actually his loving days had ceased before that because as soon as he became emperor
各种药剂或面霜。因此才会没有皱纹。没有皱纹，软膏基本上就是疯狂迷恋各种软膏。她是一个——迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说——“内心充满激情，随时准备迎接生死的女性”。现在她把赌注押在了米海尔四世身上，而这实际上错得离谱，因为一旦他——我的意思是，你虽然说当他身体水肿时柔情蜜意就到头了，但实际上他的柔情蜜意在此之前就已经停止了，因为他一当上皇帝，
he basically locked her in the women's quarters and said, I've had enough of you, don't come out. So now she's back and she's got this Michael V who's her adoptive son. Do things work out better with Michael the fifth? They do not. He is determined to have a break with his predecessor and bring in all his own people, Scythian eunuchs. So these are kind of, these may well be Slavs or Pechenegs and he'd get rid of the old guards.
基本上就把她锁在女眷的住所里，并说：“我受够你了，别出来。”所以现在她回来了，身边还有这个作为她养子的米海尔五世。事情在米海尔五世手下会有所好转吗？并没有。他决心与前任彻底决裂，引进他自己的人马——斯基泰太监。这些家伙可能是斯拉夫人或佩切涅格人——并且他要清除老卫士。
But the person he really hates with an absolute passion is Zoe. What Michael Sellers says once he had addressed her as mistress, but now the very idea made him want to bite off his own tongue and spit it away and discuss. So we'll put him down as undecided. Yeah, he's not a fan. And he waits for a few months till Easter 1042 and then he makes his move. So on Easter Sunday, these Scythian eunuchs burst into her chamber and they drag her out and they drag her before him. And he says, you, I know you've been trying to poison me.
但他恨之入骨、恨得咬牙切齿的人是佐伊。迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说，曾经他尊称她为主母，但现在一想到这个词就让他想咬掉自己的舌头，把它吐掉以示厌恶。所以我们把他的态度记为：未决。对，他不是她的粉丝。他等了几个月，直到 1042 年的复活节，然后他采取了行动。于是在复活节星期天，这些斯基泰太监闯入她的寝宫，把她强行拖了出去，并把她拖到他面前。他说：“你，我早就知道你一直在试图毒害我。”
You know, you're clearly as guilty as hell. You're going to be sent off to the Prince's islands and the sea of Marmara, just off Constantinople. And you'll be sent to a nunnery. Get thee to a nunnery. I mean, literally. So very reminiscent of what's going to happen to Edith a few years later when Edward the Confessor packs her off to a nunnery. I mean, nunneries are obviously
“你知道的，你显然罪无可赦。你将被流放到君士坦丁堡海域马尔马拉海的王子群岛。你将被送往一座修女院。”滚进修女院去吧。我是说，字面意义上的。这非常让人联想起几年后爱德华忏悔王（Edward the Confessor）把埃迪斯（Edith）打发到修女院时将要发生的事。我的意思是，修女院显然
very useful if you want to get, you know, an unwanted queen. Exactly. So we're told she was immediately put on a ship along with certain men who were given free hand to insult her. She's stripped of her purple robes and her head was shaved and I quote, as though she was a common whore. That's very harsh. Very harsh. And I imagine her hair.
非常有用，如果你想打发掉一个……你知道的，不受欢迎的王后。完全正确。于是我们得知她立刻被送上了一艘船，船上还有一些被赋予全权去侮辱她的人。她身上的紫色长袍被剥夺，头发也被剃光了，引述原话：“就像一个普通的妓女一样。”这太苛刻了。太苛刻了。而我脑海中浮现出她的头发。
Golden hair. Golden hair and much treated again with all kind of ointments and salves and permades. And now casually thrown aside, very poor. Now Michael has clearly made a massive miscalculation here because Michael Sellers, the chronicler who knows a lot about kind of court politics says, you know, everyone despised him. He was regarded as a slave to his emotions, erratic and all this. And Zoe was very popular in the city. So she has been the most glamorous person in the life of Constantinople since she was basically born in 978. She'd been born in the purple, her father was
金色的头发。金色的头发，而且再次经过各种软膏、药膏和润发脂的精心护理。而现在却被随手抛弃，极其可怜。现在米海尔显然在这里犯了一个巨大的战略错误，因为编年史家迈克尔·普瑟洛斯对宫廷政治了如指掌，他说道：“每个人都鄙视他。他被视为自己情绪的奴隶，反复无常，诸如此类。而佐伊在城里非常受欢迎。”所以自她 978 年出生以来，她一直是君士坦丁堡生活中最耀眼的人物。她生于紫色宫室，她的父亲是皇帝，她的叔叔是皇帝，她的祖父是皇帝。她是这个宫廷固有的一部分，深受民众的喜爱。所以在复活节星期一，也就是第二天，消息传遍了全城。每个人都在为这位女皇担忧。
an emperor, her uncle was an emperor, her grandfather was an emperor. She's part of the furniture and she's a great favorite of the crowds. So on Easter Monday, the next day, the word spreads to the city. Everyone was worried about the empress. Deep down men knew matters had got out of hand and they were not afraid to speak up about it, says Michael Sellers. The Emperor, Michael V, he sends the city's prefect to read out a statement in the in the forum to explain what he's done and the crowd go absolutely berserk, smashing everything up, rioting and whatnot. They end up breaking into the cathedral, Hagia Sophia, they get the patriarch to start ringing the bells, they browse the city. There's general sort of chaos and fighting and looting and stuff.
“人们内心深处知道事情已经失控了，他们并不害怕大声说出来，”迈克尔·普瑟洛斯说道。皇帝米海尔五世派了城市长官到广场上宣读一份声明，解释他所做的事情，结果民众彻底疯狂了，打砸一切，暴动等等。他们最后闯入了圣索菲亚大教堂，找来大主教开始敲响钟声，他们在城里大肆破坏。到处都是一片混乱、打斗和掠夺。
There's actually a fragment in the sagas by a guy called Valgaard who was a guardsman, a Varangian guard from Iceland who ended up becoming a Scalded poet who says, "'The flames licked the stones, crackling embers shot from the soot and columns of smoke rose vertically from the tumbling houses. You see, I think that's brilliant. And I was saying earlier how I prefer kind of blank verse to rhyming verse when it's Vikings. Also Dominic, just to say about the patriarch, Alexios, that John the eunuch, the Varys of Constantinople, he had tried to get rid of him and replace him.
萨迦中其实有一段残篇，作者是一个名叫瓦尔加德（Valgaard）的人，他是一名卫士，是来自冰岛的瓦兰吉卫队成员，后来成了一名冰岛格里斯凯尔德（Skald）诗体诗人，他写道：“烈火舔舐着石块，噼啪作响的余烬从烟灰中飞射而出，滚滚浓烟从坍塌的房屋中笔直升起。”你看，我觉得这太精彩了。我之前说过，当写到维京人时，我更喜欢无韵诗而不是押韵诗。另外多米尼克，关于大主教阿列克修斯（Alexios），太监约翰——君士坦丁堡的瓦里斯——曾试图摆脱他并换掉他。
And there's all kinds of weird political currents that we can only vaguely glimpse, I think, that are going on, including the Varangians. So the Varangians, their loyalty is pledged to the imperial family. They are mercenaries working for the imperial family. And I think it's a fair assumption that they feel very put out about the arrival of these Scythian eunuchs. The Pechenegs. And there's some form of power struggle, I think, between the two of them. And my guess is that they are probably in on this riot. And it's all been planned and it's actually a little bit
这里面有各种各样的政治暗流，我们只能隐约窥见一二，包括瓦兰吉卫队。所以瓦兰吉卫队，他们的忠诚是对着皇室宣誓的。他们是为皇室效力的雇佣兵。我认为可以合理推测，他们对这些斯基泰太监的到来感到非常恼火。也就是佩切涅格人。我认为他们两者之间存在某种形式的权力争夺。而我的猜测是，他们很可能参与了这场暴动。这一切都是策划好的，与其说这是一场暴动，不如说它更像是一场反政变。总之，到周一下午，这已经演变成了一场大规模的街头战。
more of a counter-coup than it is really a riot. Anyway, by the Monday afternoon, it's become a massive street battle. It's Michael and his Scythians against the mob and the Varangians. And on the Tuesday, I mean, this would be a superb kind of HBO series or something. Cause on Tuesday, the attackers break into the palace, partly through the emperor's box in the Hippodrome, which has a tunnel leading through to the, to the palace or corridor. They kind of fight their way into the Imperial quarters. And guess what?
米海尔和他的斯基泰人对抗暴民和瓦兰吉卫队。到了周二——我的意思是，这会是一部极棒的 HBO 电视剧之类的内容。因为在周二，攻击者闯入了皇宫，部分是通过竞技场（Hippodrome）里皇帝的包厢，那里有一条通往皇宫或走廊的地道。他们一路杀进皇宫内寝。你猜怎么着？
Michael has escaped. He's gone off with his uncle, Constantine. They've gone down to the dock. The palace has its own dock. They've rushed down to the dock. They grab an Imperial yacht. I love it that they have yachts. They have Imperial yachts.
米海尔逃跑了。他和他的叔叔康斯坦丁一起跑了。他们逃到了码头。皇宫有自己的码头。他们冲到码头。抢夺了一艘皇家游艇。我太喜欢他们居然有游艇这事了。他们有皇家游艇。
I know. And then they head off in this yacht. But it's obviously not an ocean going yacht because they can only go so far. So actually they just go down. They don't even really get out of the city. They dock by the Studios Monastery, which is near the city walls, and they get out and they go to find sanctuary in the monastery. Now in the meantime, the rioters have got hold of Zoe. She's been brought back from the island, shaving her head, which is sad.
我知道。然后他们坐着这艘游艇出发了。但这显然不是远洋游艇，所以他们开不了多远。实际上他们只是顺流而下。他们甚至都没有真正离开这座城。他们在靠近城墙的斯图迪奥斯修道院（Studios Monastery）旁停靠，下船去修道院寻求庇护。与此同时，暴徒们找到了佐伊。她被从岛上带了回来，头上还剃了光头，这很令人难过。
They've also dug out her sister, Theodora, who's been in a nunnery for eight years. She's been in a nunnery for ages. Willingly or? No, I think slightly unwillingly. Yeah, okay. So they dug her out. They've got the two of them and they say, right, we want you to rule as co-empresses. Let's just get rid of this Michael bloke.
他们还把她的妹妹狄奥多拉（Theodora）挖了出来，后者已经在修女院里呆了八年了。她在修女院里呆了好久了。是自愿的还是？不，我觉得稍微有点不情愿。好吧。所以他们把她挖出来了。他们找到了她们俩，并说：“好啦，我们要你们作为共治女皇来统治。让我们把这个叫米海尔的家伙赶下台吧。”
We hate him. So what to do with him? A load of rioters and Varangian guards break into this monastery, totally ignoring all the stuff about sanctuary. They drag him and his uncle outside. Now at this point I have to say Michael, who's behaved poorly I think throughout, he completely shames himself. He does not react as a Viking would react. A Viking would meet his death with a quip and a poem. So how would you react in this situation? With a quip and a poem. I've already told react in this situation? With a quip and a poem.
我们恨他。那该怎么对付他呢？一群暴徒和瓦兰吉亚卫队闯进这座修道院，完全无视关于庇护所的种种规矩。他们把他和他的叔叔强行拖到外面。现在，我必须得说，迈克尔此前表现得很差劲，我觉得他这会儿彻底把脸丢尽了。他的反应一点也不像个维京人。维京人面对死亡时应该带着俏皮话和一首诗。那你在这种情况下会怎么反应？带着俏皮话和一首诗。我已经说过在这种情况会怎么反应了？带着俏皮话和一首诗。
I've already told you. Yes, I think I would. Okay. There's no doubt in my mind. I hope the opportunity doesn't come about for me to hold you to that. Well, if I'm ever taking sanctuary in a monastery in present day Istanbul and rioters and Scandinavians drag me out, I hope I don't do what he does, which is he clings to the altar, sobbing like a baby.
我已经告诉你了。是的，我想我会的。好吧。我对此深信不疑。我希望我可别有机会抓着这个把柄不放。好吧，如果我哪天在如今伊斯坦布尔的一座修道院里寻求庇护，结果被暴徒和斯堪的纳维亚人拖出去，我希望我不会像他那样，抱着祭坛像个婴儿一样号啕大哭。
Then he clings to the pillars, weeping, praying to God and worse saying, it was all my uncle's fault. I never wanted to do it. That's the, that's the, that's low. I would do that. That would be me. So they take him outside. They hold him down. This is a bit that younger listeners will very much enjoy.
接着他抱住柱子，痛哭流涕，向上帝祈祷，更糟的是，他还说：“这都是我叔叔的错。我从来没想过要这么做。”这、这实在是太卑鄙了。我会那么做。那肯定是我。于是他们把他带到外面。把他按倒在地。这一段年轻的听众一定会非常喜欢。
He's screaming and shouting and they gouge out his eyes. So the point of doing that is if you're mutilated, you can't continue to be emperor. Right, as with kings. So it's what Godwin has done to Alfred back in England, gouging out the eyes. As with that, there's always the risk that you may end up killing the person you blinded. Well, risk, is that a risk or is that an added bonus, Tom? Well, yes, I suppose. So this does make me wonder more about Harald Hardrada.
他尖叫着、呐喊着，而他们挖出了他的双眼。这么做的目的在于，如果你被弄残了，你就不能继续当皇帝了。没错，国王也是如此。正如戈德温当年在英格兰对阿尔弗雷德做的那样，被挖出了双眼。正因如此，你总会有最终把被弄瞎的人弄死的风险。好吧，这算风险，还是算额外福利呢，汤姆？嗯，是的，我想是吧。所以这让我对哈拉尔·哈德拉达（Harald Hardrada）产生了更多好奇。
The sagas say the person who does the eye gouging is Harald. He's the person who did it. So this is in King Harald's saga. It's a scald called Theodolf. He wrote this, the warrior who fed the wolves ripped out both the eyes of the emperor of the Greeks. The warrior-king of Norway marked his cruel revenge on the Emperor of the East." And Snorri the chronicler, writing two centuries later, he says,
萨迦传说中挖眼的人正是哈拉尔。他就是下手的人。这记载在《哈拉尔国王萨迦》中。有一位名叫西奥多尔夫（Theodolf）的斯卡尔德（即吟游诗人）写道：“那个喂饱了狼群的勇士，挖出了希腊皇帝的双眼。挪威的勇士国王，在东罗马皇帝身上留下了他残酷的复仇印记。”而两个世纪后写作的编年史家斯诺里（Snorri）则说：
In these songs and many others, it is said that Harold himself blinded the Greek Emperor, and they would surely have named some Duke-Ccount or other great man if they had not known this to be the true account. And King Harold himself and other men who were with him spread this account." So the historical method in operation there. So there is the historical method at the heart of the Icelandic sagas. Men said it, numerous sources, we've sifted the sources, and it's very clear that Harold Hardrada did this gouging. So you may well say, all's well that ends well. Michael, Seans eyes, he dies of his wounds a few months later. There may also have been some castration involved, the sources differ on that.
“在这些诗歌以及许多其他作品中，都说哈拉尔本人弄瞎了希腊皇帝的眼睛，如果他们明知这不是事实，就一定会说出某个公爵、伯爵或其他大人物的名字。哈拉尔国王本人以及随行的其他人都在传播这种说法。”历史研究方法就在那里发挥作用了。这就是冰岛萨迦核心的历史研究方法。人们这么说了，有众多的消息来源，我们梳理了这些来源，并且很清楚哈拉尔·哈德拉达确实干了这件挖眼的事。所以你可能会说，结局好，一切都好。迈克尔·塞勒斯的眼睛……几个月后他因伤势过重而死。其中可能还包含一些阉割的情节，史料对此众说纷纭。
I don't know if Harold was also responsible for that. Let's say he was. So he didn't write a poem about that? No, he didn't write that. He scattered the genitals far. Yeah. If listeners want to send in their own poems, I wonder what that poem would be like. Harry in for the Ravens. Address them please to Tom Holland, courtesy of Goalhanger. Zoe and Theodora reign briefly as co-empresses,
我不知道哈拉尔是不是也对此负有责任。我们就假设他是吧。所以他没为此写首诗？不，他没写那首诗。他把那些生殖器到处乱撒。是的。如果听众想寄来他们自己的诗，我不知道那会是什么样的诗。哈里，送给乌鸦们的。请寄给汤姆·霍兰，转交高挂鸟制作公司（Goalhanger）。佐伊（Zoe）和狄奥多拉（Theodora）短暂地作为共同女皇统治，
and then Zoe marries a nobleman and he becomes Constantine the Ninth. Now clearly the Varangians have really benefited from this. They regain their old position at the top of the tree. Harold is their commander. We're told that a lot of gold changes hands, so Michael Sellers. The revenues budgeted for the military were set aside for the use of others, a cluster of sycophants and those who were appointed to guard the empresses. So that's Harold, Harold and the Varangian guards. So things appear to have worked out brilliantly for him. He's now very rich, is more powerful than ever. He's the right hand of the Empress, a
随后佐伊嫁给了一位贵族，后者成为了君士坦丁九世。现在很显然，瓦兰吉亚人从这当中获益匪浅。他们恢复了以往在权势巅峰的地位。哈拉尔成了他们的指挥官。我们被告知有大量的黄金易手，所以迈克尔·塞勒斯……原本为军队预算的收入被挪作他用，落入了一群谄媚者和那些被指派去保护女皇的人手中。所以这就是哈拉尔、哈拉尔和瓦兰吉亚卫队。因此事情对他的发展似乎极为美妙。他现在非常富有，比以往任何时候都更有权势。他是女皇的左膀右臂，
genuine player in the politics of Europe's most glittering empire. All looks good. And then, Tom, one day he is woken by a ferocious hammering on his door. When he opens it, he sees guards outside and their faces are cold. And admirers of Dominic's Adventures in Time series will know that when guards with cold faces appear on the scene, excitement is bound to follow. A giant snake is never far away. And so adventure will follow in the second part of this super soreaway episode. We'll see you then. This episode is brought to you by FX's Dying for Sex on Disney+. Based on the podcast of
是欧洲最耀眼帝国政治中的真正玩家。一切看起来都很顺利。然后，汤姆，有一天他被一阵疯狂砸门的巨响惊醒。当他打开门时，他看到外面站着卫兵，他们的面孔冷冰冰的。多米尼克的《时间历险记》系列的粉丝们都会知道，当面色冰冷的卫兵出现在现场时，刺激的事必然随之而来。巨蛇从不远游。因此，冒险将在这一超级精彩爽快的剧集的第二部分继续。我们到时见。本节目由迪士尼+（Disney+）旗下的FX剧集《为性而死》（Dying for Sex）为您倾情呈现。该剧改编自同名播客，
the same name, Dying for Sex tells the+. Based on the podcast of the same name, Dying for Sex tells the story of Molly, who is diagnosed with stage four breast cancer. Determined to feel everything she can before she can't feel anything, she decides to leave her unhappy marriage to explore her sexuality, with some encouragement from her best friend, Nikki.
《为性而死》讲述了莫莉（Molly）的故事，她被诊断出患有乳腺癌晚期。在无法感受任何事物之前，她决心去感受她所能感受到的一切，在好友妮基（Nikki）的鼓励下，她决定结束不幸福的婚姻去探索自己的性欲。
FX's Dying for Sex, streaming April 4th, only on Disney Plus. Sign up now at DisneyPlus.com. Are you crushing your bills? Defeating your monthly payments. Sounds like you're at the top of your financial game. Rise to it with the BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card. The credit card that rewards your good financial habits.
FX的《为性而死》，4月4日上线，独家登陆迪士尼+。现在就登录DisneyPlus.com注册吧。你是否在轻松清算账单？战胜你的每月付款。听起来你已经达到了财务巅峰。使用BMO卓越理财优越Visa卡（BMO Eclipse Rise Visa Card）来应对挑战。这是一张能够奖励你良好理财习惯的信用卡。
Unpoints for paying your credit card bill rewards your good financial habits. Earn points for paying your credit card bill in full and on time every month. Level up from bill payer to reward slayer. Terms and conditions apply. Let's drive good together with Bonterra and Volkswagen. Buy any sustainably focused Bonterra bathroom tissue, paper towel or facial tissue and you could win a 2025 Volkswagen all-electric ID buzz. See in store for details. Bonterra for a better planet. No purchase necessary. Terms and conditions apply. See online for details. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. So Dominic, cold-faced guards have intruded on Harold, absolute cliffhanger. What's going on?
按时全额支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分，它能奖励你良好的理财习惯。每个月按时全额支付信用卡账单即可赚取积分。从账单支付者升级为奖励收割者。须遵守条款与条件。让我们与邦特拉（Bonterra）和大众汽车（Volkswagen）一起共创美好未来。购买任何注重可持续发展的邦特拉浴室纸巾、厨房纸巾或面巾纸，即有机会赢得2025款大众全电动ID. Buzz。详情请见店内海报。邦特拉，为了更美好的地球。无需购买。须遵守条款与条件。详情请查看在线说明。你好，欢迎回到《历史本该如此》（The Rest Is History）。那么，多米尼克，面色冰冷的卫兵闯入了哈拉尔的生活，真是绝对的悬念啊。这到底是怎么回事？
Well, this is a good point to stop and ask ourselves how true any of this story is. So as we said in the first episode, any biography of Harold Hardrada has to rely on these very colourful sagas that have three massive problems. Number one, they're written down centuries later. Number two, they often wildly contradict each other and the stuff in Constantinople is often incredibly confused and contradictory. And number three, as we've said before, many of the elements of them are clearly fantastical. So for the stuff we would have been describing, you describing, effectively what biographers of Harold are doing is trying to stitch together a plausible narrative out of disparate elements in the
嗯，这是一个停下来问问我们自己，这个故事到底有几分真实的绝佳时机。正如我们在第一集里所说的那样，任何关于哈拉尔·哈德拉达的传记都不得不依赖于这些非常绚丽多彩的萨迦，而它们存在三个巨大问题。第一，它们是在几个世纪后才被书写下来的。第二，它们往往彼此严重矛盾，而且关于君士坦丁堡的记载通常极其混乱和自相矛盾。第三，正如我们以前所说，其中的许多元素显然都是奇幻虚构的。因此，对于我们刚才一直在描述的那些内容，实际上哈拉尔的传记作家们所做的，就是试图从萨迦中那些截然不同的元素里拼凑出一个貌似合理的叙事。
sagas. And that is assuming that any of it might be true. That any of it, but we know that some of it clearly is true because of the, for example, the stuff about Auraltes. Right, but his involvement in what was clearly a very celebrated episode. If he's your hero, you would want to intrude him into something like that. I mean, it would be like, you know, kind of flash man or something. Yeah.
而这还是建立在这些内容可能有哪怕一点真实性的基础上的。任何内容，但我们知道其中有些内容显然是真的，比如，关于奥尔特（Auraltes）的事。没错，但如果他参与了一个显然非常著名的事件，如果你把这人当成英雄，你就会想把他硬塞进这样的情节里。我的意思是，这就有点像，你知道的，某种“闪光侠”（Flashman）式的人物。是的。
The eye gouging. There's a bit of a flash man quality, isn't it? So Harold, I'll try it in his life. Slightly. So there are three elements that we haven't fitted in that appear in the sagas that historians and biographers have sort of grappled with. Number one, at some point Harold is imprisoned, possibly by Zoe. Number two, there is some kind of love affair, possibly with Zoe, but probably
挖眼。这有点“闪光侠”的特质，不是吗？所以哈拉尔，他在生前尝试过。有点像。因此，还有三个萨迦中出现但我们尚未融入的元素，历史学家和传记作家们一直在努力解决它们。第一，在某个时刻哈拉尔被监禁了，可能是由佐伊下令。第二，发生了一段某种程度上的恋情，对象可能是佐伊，但可能
not, probably with an aristocrat called Maria. And number three, there is a death-defying escape by ship from Constantinople. And they could be completely made up, but they might not be. Can I just ask Dominic, I mean, the key thing for Harold has been to get gold. Yes. And so the question hanging over all of this, if there is, you know, he doesn't get locked up and escapes and makes a death defying escape on a ship, as we will explore, where is his gold?
不是，可能是一位名叫玛丽亚的贵族女性。第三，是一场从君士坦丁堡死里逃生的船只大逃亡。这些可能是完全虚构的，但也可能并非如此。请问多米尼克，我的意思是，对哈拉尔来说，最关键的事情一直是弄到黄金。是的。所以所有这一切背后悬而未决的问题是，如果有的话——他没有被关起来然后逃跑，并像我们接下来要探讨的那样，进行了一场死里逃生的船只大逃亡——他的黄金在哪里？
How is he getting his gold out? Has he sent it back already or what is happening there? The answer to that is very straightforward. He has already been sending it back because we are told in the sagas quote, all the gold he had sent ahead from Constantinople, a treasure hoard so immense that no one in Northern Europe could recall ever seeing so much wealth in one man's possession and sent ahead to Kiev, to Yaroslav, to his prospective father-in-law. And he may say, well, why didn't Yaroslav just steal it?
他是怎么把黄金运出来的？他是已经提前把它寄回去了，还是发生了什么？这个问题的答案非常简单。他其实已经提前把黄金寄回去了，因为萨迦中记载道：“他从君士坦丁堡提前运回的所有黄金，是一笔如此庞大的财富，以至于北欧没有任何人能回想起曾见过一个人拥有如此巨额的财富，这些财富被提前运到了基辅，运到了雅罗斯拉夫（Yaroslav），运给了他未来的岳父。”你可能会问，那雅罗斯拉夫为什么不直接把它们偷走呢？
The answer is, if he's gonna get it anyway as a bride price for his daughter, Elisif, he doesn't need to steal it. And also, clearly, Harold isn't the kind of person you want to get on the wrong side of. So to return to these three elements that we haven't fitted in, different historians and different biographers
答案是，既然他无论如何作为他女儿伊丽丝芙（Elisif）的彩礼都能得到这些黄金，他就没必要去偷。而且很显然，哈拉尔也不是那种你想去惹麻烦的人。所以回到我们刚才没有融进叙事的那三个元素，不同的历史学家和不同的传记作家
propose different combinations. There's a really fun one in the most recent biography of Harold Hardrada, which is a book called The Last Viking by the American writer Don Holway and it kind of makes some sense so let's go with that. The sagas say Zoe had always had a great fondness for Harold. There is this I think probably made up story that at one point she said to him I'd love a lock of your fair hair and he said her, Let us make an even trade of it, Majesty, you give me one of your nether hairs." So very Lord Byron behaviour. Very Lord Byron. I don't believe if Rangin Guard would have
提出了不同的组合。在哈拉尔·哈德拉达最新的一部传记中，有一个非常有趣的版本，那是美国作家唐·霍洛韦（Don Holway）写的一本名为《最后的维京人》（The Last Viking）的书，它在某种程度上说得通，所以我们就讲这个版本吧。萨迦说，佐伊一直非常喜爱哈拉尔。有一个我认为可能是虚构的故事说，有一次她对他说：“我很想要你的一缕金发，”而他对她说：“陛下，让我们做个公平的交易吧，你给我一根你的下体毛发。”这真是一种拜伦勋爵式的行为。非常拜伦。我不相信一个瓦兰吉亚卫队会
spoken like that to the Empress. It seems just very implausible. Anyway, maybe she did have a fondness for him, and clearly if he was involved in the counter coup against Michael V, she would owe him a debt and she would feel they had a relationship of some kind. Now King Harold's saga says, at this point he falls in love. There was a young and beautiful girl called Maria, brother's daughter of the Empress Zoe, and Harold asked for her hand in marriage but the Empress gave him refusal. The Varangians then in Constantinople have told people here in the north that it was said by well-informed
对女皇说出这样的话。这看起来太不合情理了。不管怎样，也许她确实很喜欢他，而且很显然，如果他参与了反对迈克尔五世的反政变，她就会欠他一个人情，并且她会觉得他们之间某种程度上存在某种关系。现在，《哈拉尔国王萨迦》写道，在此时他坠入了爱河。有一个年轻貌美的女孩叫玛丽亚，是女皇佐伊的兄弟的女儿，哈拉尔向她求婚，但女皇拒绝了他。当时在君士坦丁堡的瓦兰吉亚人曾对北方这里的人说，消息灵通的人士
people that the Empress Zoe herself wanted Harold for her husband, although another reason was given out to the public. So what's going on here? There actually is a woman called Maria hanging around at the court at this time. She's not Zoe's niece, but she is her husband, Constantine's niece. It's like the beginning of a very bad play. And what is more, she is Constantine's mistress. So this person does definitely exist.
曾透露，女皇佐伊本人其实是想让哈拉尔做她的丈夫，尽管当时向公众公布的是另一个原因。那么这里到底发生了什么？当时宫廷里确实闲逛着一个名叫玛丽亚的女人。她不是佐伊的侄女，而是佐伊的丈夫君士坦丁的侄女。这听起来像是一出非常糟糕的戏剧的开场。而且更重要的是，她是君士坦丁的情妇。所以这个人物确实是存在的。
Maria Sclerina. In looks says Michael Sellers, Sclerina was nothing special, but by her character and wits, she could charm a heart of stone. Her voice was musical. In conversation, she had a natural lilt, an indescribable style of telling a story. At any rate, says the chronicler, she certainly bewitched me. You know, that is a passage entirely left from Plutarch's Life of Cleopatra. I mean, Life of Antony.
玛丽亚·斯克莉娜（Maria Sclerina）。迈克尔·塞勒斯说，从外表上看，斯克莉娜并没有什么特别之处，但凭借她的性格和机智，她能迷住铁石心肠的人。她的声音如音乐般动听。在谈话中，她有一种自然的抑扬顿挫，有一种难以言表的讲故事风格。总之，编年史家说，她确实把我迷住了。你知道，那段话完全照搬自普鲁塔克的《安东尼传》。我的意思是，是《安东尼传》。
Exactly. That's the interesting thing about it. It's a portrait. She's not great looking, but her voice is musical. She can speak all these different tongues. She has it when she tells a story, all of this kind of thing. So again, a literary formula within a source. Anyway, she exists. We know that she was Constantine's mistress. They conducted their affair very openly. Is it possible that Harold also carried on with her? I would say personally, very unlikely. But the sagas do insist, different sagas insist that he had taken a fancy to somebody called Maria and that Zoe didn't like it. So this is another saga called the Morkin's Ginner. Nordbricht and Maria continued their affair and at this time, Empress Zoe
没错。这就是它有趣的地方。这是一个肖像描写。她长得不算绝色，但声音如音乐般甜美。她能说各种不同的语言。她在讲故事时自带某种风范，诸如此类。所以，这再次体现了某种历史资料中的文学套路。不管怎样，她确实存在。我们知道她是君士坦丁的情妇。他们的风流韵事相当公开。哈拉尔有可能也跟她有一腿吗？我个人认为，可能性非常低。但萨迦确实坚称——不同的萨迦都坚称——他对一个叫玛丽亚的人产生了爱慕之情，而佐伊对此很不高兴。所以这是另一部名为《莫金斯基纳》（Morkinskinna）的萨迦。诺德布里希（Nordbricht，即哈拉尔）和玛丽亚继续着他们的私情，而此时，女皇佐伊
developed a burning hatred for Nordbricht. Remember that was his alias. So eventually, if the sagas had been believed, Zoe snapped. She accused him of being familiar with the maiden Maria. The emperor had Nordbrok seized and bound and taken to a dungeon. The King Harold saga has great fun with this. The prison was on high open topped tower with the cell door at street level. Harold was shoved through this door together with Haldor and Ulf. So that's Legolas and Gimli.
对诺德布里希燃起了炽烈的恨意。记住，那是他的化名。所以最终，如果相信萨迦的记载，佐伊爆发了。她指控他与少女玛丽亚关系暧昧。皇帝下令将诺德布里克抓捕并捆绑起来，关进了一个地牢里。《哈拉尔国王萨迦》对这段情节进行了极大的艺术渲染。监狱位于一座高耸、露天的塔楼里，牢房的门开在街道水平面上。哈拉尔被从这扇门推进去，同行的还有哈尔多（Haldor）和乌尔夫（Ulf）。也就是莱戈拉斯（Legolas）和吉姆利（Gimli）。
Legolas and Gimli. So Aragorn, Legolas and Gimli are in this flipping prison. It's dark, it's damp, it's full of bodies, just like you'd want a Tolkien-esque prison to be. And Haldor is in the cell because he's given this excellent line. He says, it's not brilliant, but I suppose it could be worse. And then it does turn out worse. And then they see the snake rises from the water. There was a huge venomous serpent that slept by the stream trickling through the cell. The serpent fed on the corpses of men who crossed the emperor or his lords and was subsequently thrown down there.
莱戈拉斯和吉姆利。所以阿拉贡、莱戈拉斯和吉姆利被关在这个该死的监狱里。这里面黑暗、潮湿、到处都是尸体，完全符合你对托尔斯泰（注：应为托尔斯泰式，原文Tolkien-esque实为托尔斯金式）风格监狱的想象。哈尔多在牢房里，因为他说了这句绝妙的台词。他说：“这不算太妙，但我猜情况也可能更糟。”然后情况果然变得更糟了。接着他们看到一条蛇从水中探出头来。有一条巨大的毒蛇，就睡在顺着牢房缓缓流过的小溪旁。这条蛇以那些得罪了皇帝或其领主、随后被扔进地牢里的人的尸体为食。
That's the Morkinskinner saga. So some sagas say a serpent, some say a dragon. I mean, it is possible there was a snake in this prison and that it existed. Of course, it's more likely if this is all a mad, it's going to bear wolf-style fantasy. Anyway, in the sagas, as you described in that beautiful reading, Tom, Harold gets a stick and finally he manages to jab the stick in this snake's mouth and then stabs it in the heart with a knife. This kind of Lord of the Rings style action. Now if you think that's bonkers and a bit implausible, what then happens, he has a vision.
这是《莫金斯基纳》萨迦的记载。所以有些萨迦说是一条蛇，有些说是一条巨龙。我的意思是，这座监狱里确实可能有一条蛇，它也确实存在。当然，如果这一切都是一场疯狂的、充满熊狼风格（Bear-Wolf style，一种奇幻风格）的幻想，那它更可能是不真实的。无论如何，在萨迦中，正如你刚才在美妙的朗读中所描述的那样，汤姆，哈拉尔拿了一根棍子，最后他成功地用棍子捅进这条蛇的嘴里，然后用一把小刀刺入了它的心脏。这种指环王风格的动作戏。现在，如果你觉得这太荒谬、太不可信了，那么接下来发生的事情是：他出现了一个幻象。
His dead brother Olaf, he's been off the stage for a while but he's back. He appears to Harold in a vision and says, look, links look bleak for you, but don't worry, I will get you out. They stay in this prison for two nights and then they hear a woman's voice at the door, would you like to be rescued? And she says, I'm a noble woman. She never gives her name. She always wears a hood and is kind of very mysterious.
他的死去的兄弟奥拉夫（Olaf）——他已经离开舞台一段时间了，但他又回来了。他在一个幻象中出现在哈拉尔面前并说：“看，你的处境看起来很暗淡，但别担心，我会带你出去的。”他们在监狱里待了两晚，然后他们听到门口有一个女人的声音问：“你们想被营救吗？”她说：“我是一个贵族女性。”她从不透露自己的名字。她总是戴着风帽，显得非常神秘。
When they say, well, who are you? She says, your brother, King Olaf appeared to me in a dream and told me to come and rescue you. And she lowers a rope to them. She and her servants haul them up up this rope and then a massive game of Thrones scene. They run through the night back to the Varangian barracks. They get their weapons. They wake their mates back into the night through the darkness down to the harbor. They get down to the harbor. They seize two galleys. They row out into the golden horn and then a total disaster. The golden horn is blocked as it always was by a huge chain, a barrier chain,
当他们问：“好吧，你是谁？”她说：“你的兄弟奥拉夫国王在一个梦中出现在我面前，让我来救你们。”接着她向他们垂下一根绳子。她和她的仆人们把他们顺着这根绳子拉了上去，随后便上演了一场大规模的《权力的游戏》式的场景。他们连夜跑回瓦兰吉亚人的军营。他们拿到武器。他们唤醒同伴，在黑夜中穿行，一路向下奔向港口。他们到达港口。他们夺取了两艘桨帆船。他们划向金角湾，然而接着就是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。金角湾像往常一样被一条巨大的铁链阻断了，那是一道屏障铁链，
sealing it off from the Bosphorus. And so Harold comes up with a brilliant scheme. He says, listen, everybody piled down to the back of the galley. So weigh it down. So it kind of, your mighty weight is a great weight. Well, if they're 10 feet tall, all of these people, and Gimli's a dwarf, isn't he? Jump up and down. They weigh these boats down. So they're, they're angled out of the water.
将其与博斯普鲁斯海峡隔离开来。于是哈拉尔想出了一个绝妙的计策。他说：“听着，所有人全都挤到桨帆船的船尾去。”把它压重。这样它就会……由于你们庞大的体重，成了一个巨大的重量。好吧，如果这些人都有十英尺高，而吉姆利是个侏儒，对吧？他们上下跳跃。他们把这些船只压得很重。所以它们在水面上翘了起来。
And then they sort of like, I don't know, like Roger Moore and the man with the golden gun or something, they're able to kind of rock over the chain. Harold Hardrata's eyebrow is going even higher than it normally is. Exactly. And definitely he likes a quip, you know, so there must be some, I wish I could think of some Roger Moore style quip that he makes. You'll never chain me up again. I don't know.
然后他们就好像……我不知道，就像罗杰·摩尔（Roger Moore）在《金枪人》电影里那样，他们能够以某种方式摇晃着越过那条铁链。哈拉尔·哈德拉达的眉毛抬得比平时还要高了。没错。而且他显然很喜欢俏皮话，你知道的，所以他肯定会说些什么，我真希望自己能想出几句他会说的罗杰·摩尔风格的俏皮话。你再也休想用铁链锁住我。我不知道。
Who knows? Anyway, they get out, one boat breaks up, a lot of the people drown, but they manage to haul the others onto their Harold's boat. Great cheers. As day breaks over the Bocerus, they turn north towards the black sea and safety. Unbelievable. They have escaped. What an amazing scene.
谁知道呢？无论如何，他们逃出去了，其中一艘船撞毁了，许多人淹死了，但他们设法把其他人拉到了哈拉尔的船上。欢呼声雷动。当曙光照亮博斯普鲁斯海峡时，他们向北转向黑海，驶向安全地带。简直难以置信。他们逃出来了。多麽惊人的场面啊！
And the question that may be in some listeners' minds, has the rest of this history degenerated into mad fan fiction? And the answer is probably yes. I would guess there are some elements of this, a feud at court, an internal power struggle, Harold wanting to get the remainder of his gold out of Constantinople. Will you mentioned this book, which I haven't read, Don Holloway, The Last Viking. What is his suggestion? He just loves this story and tells it in great detail.
有些听众心里可能会有个疑问：这档《历史本该如此》节目是不是已经退化成了疯狂的同人小说（fan fiction）？而答案很可能是：是的。我猜这里面有些元素是真实存在的——宫廷内部的权力倾轧、内部权力斗争，以及哈拉尔想要把剩下的黄金弄出君士坦丁堡。你提到了这本我没读过的书——唐·霍洛韦的《最后的维京人》。他有什么看法？
I mean, does he have some perspective on? Well, I think he says it's, you know, it's possible that there was some, that there was a dragon, not the giant snake, but there could be an internal feud. Zoe is, you know, she's, I think it's fair to say quite high maintenance. And, you know, there's a lot of politics. She has got a new husband who maybe resents the influence of the Varangian commander. Okay. Maybe Harold says, I want to go now.
我的意思是，他对此有什么独特的视角吗？嗯，我想他说的是……你知道的，有些事情是可能的，比如确实有一条龙（不是那条巨蛇），但可能存在内部权力斗争。佐伊呢，我认为可以公平地说，她是一个相当“高维护”（high-maintenance）的人。而且，你知道的，这里面有很多政治斗争。她有一个新丈夫，可能对瓦兰吉亚指挥官的势力心存嫉妒。好吧。也许哈拉尔说：“我现在想走了。
I've had enough. And they say, we don't want you to go. You're the head of the guard. You know, what do you want you to go back to Norway for? Okay. Anyway, he gets away. Yeah. There's an alternative explanation, which is there is going to be another Kievan
我已经受够了。”而他们说：“我们不想让你走。你是卫队的统领。你知道的，你回挪威去干什么？”好吧。无论如何，他逃走了。是的。还有另一种解释，那就是在接下来的几年里，基辅罗斯将对君士坦丁堡发动另一次进攻。是的。因为那是雅罗斯拉夫派兵发动的，对吧？雅罗斯拉夫派人发动的。所以还有另一种解释，那就是他离开是因为他得到了消息，说我们正计划发动进攻，城里可能会对瓦兰吉亚人进行报复，这也是合乎情理的。事情的真相究竟如何，汤姆，我们不得而知。
Rus attack on Constantinople in the next few years. Yes. Cause Yaroslav sends that, doesn't he? Yaroslav sends one. So there is an alternative explanation, which is he leaves because he's had word get out because we're planning to attack and there may be vengeance against Varangians in the city, which is again, plausible. The truth of the matter, Tom, we don't know.
我们真的不知道。是的。我们确实知道的是，大约在1043年左右，他回到了基辅。从他离开算起已经过去10年了。他现在28岁。他是一个极其富有的人。他有足够的钱来支付彩礼。伊丽丝芙现在19岁了。
We just don't know. Yeah. What we do know is that probably by about 1043, he gets back to Kyiv. It's 10 years now since he went. He is 28 years old. He's an extremely rich man. He has enough money for the bride price. Elisipha is now 19.
因此，10年前那种多少有点荒谬的年龄差距，现在她19岁了，看起来就没那么让人担忧了。他的事迹名声——当然，到斯诺里·斯图鲁松坐下来把它们写下来时，这些事迹已经被大大夸大了，但即使在当时，他的名气大概也已经从君士坦丁堡向北流传开来了，你觉得呢？我想绝对是的。我认为，作为瓦兰吉亚卫队的指挥官，在那个时候，这可能是基督教世界中最负盛名的军事单位。而且还是罗马皇帝的卫队，你知道的，这可不是闹着玩的。这是一件很严肃的事情。他根基非常稳固。他显然拥有大量的人脉。这就完全合情合理了，雅罗斯拉夫会非常渴望
So that age gap that was a bit preposterous 10 years ago looks slightly less alarming now that she's 19 years old. The fame of his deeds, which obviously are massively amplified by the time that Snorrius Dulleson sits down to write them up, but even at this point, presumably his renown is percolating northwards from Constantinople, do you think? I think definitely. I think Commander of the Varangian Guard, at that point, the most celebrated military unit probably in the Christian world. And the Roman Emperor's Guard, you know, that's not nothing. That's a serious thing. He's very well established. He's obviously got loads of contacts. He is, it makes complete sense that Yaroslav would be very keen to
把女儿嫁给他，因为你知道吗，如果他带着所有的黄金回到斯堪的纳维亚并夺回王位，他就能成为北方世界地缘政治中的一个有用盟友。但同时，他在君士坦丁堡取得了成功，这大概也让人们……你知道的，认识他的人都为此感到自豪。是的，当然。这就好像某个本土球星去了某个极其星光熠熠的海外俱乐部，然后带着一堆荣誉凯旋而归。
marry him to his daughter, because you know what, if he does get back with all his gold to Scandinavia and gets his throne back, he could be a useful ally in the kind of geopolitics of the Northern world. But also the fact that he has made it in Constantinople, presumably also people are kind of, you know, people who know him are proud of that. Yeah, of course. It's like a kind of local striker going to some massively glamorous overseas club and then coming back kind of garlanded with awards.
完全正确。这就是一个你想去结交的人。这是一个名人。这是一个招募新兵绝不会遇到任何困难的人。因为大家都想追随他。当然，也有这方面的原因。是的。所以他们结婚了，很可能是在基辅的圣索菲亚大教堂举行婚礼。
Exactly right. Here's a man who you want to know. Here's a celebrity. Here's a man who will have no problem raising recruits. Because to serve with him. Of course, and there's that as well. Yeah. So they're married, probably in the Cathedral of St. Sophia in Kiev.
几乎可以肯定，婚礼是按东正教的仪式举行的，有大量砸碎酒杯、捆绑双手以及加戴皇冠之类的仪式。但关于哈拉尔，最有趣的一点是，你可能会以为所有的风光都在南方，所有的金钱也都在南方，但实际上，他身上的挪威属性显然占据着极大的分量。他渴望回到挪威，去收复他眼中属于自己的王位，并为他的兄弟复仇。因此，斯诺里·斯图鲁松在描述这场婚姻时说，他赢得了一位公主，更不用说还得到了一大笔宝藏。而这一点在任何时候都处于最核心的地位，这听起来相当真实。
According almost certainly to the Orthodox rites, there's a lot of smashing of glasses and binding of hands and kind of crowns and stuff. But the thing that's interesting about Harald is you might think that all the glamour is in the South and all the money is in the South, but actually the Norwegian side of him clearly matters enormously. He's desperate to get back to Norway to reclaim what he sees as his throne and to avenge his brother. So Snorri Sturluson in his description of the marriage says he gained a princess, not to mention a hoard of treasure. And that's always kind of uppermost and that sounds quite authentic.
是的，我也这么认为，绝对如此。但他渴望这笔宝藏是有原因的。而这一点在任何时候都处于最核心的地位，这听起来相当真实。是的，我也这么认为。绝对如此。但他渴望这笔宝藏是有原因的。而原因就是，你知道的，王冠对他的意义重大。现在，在他离开的这15年里——因为记住他离开时还是个少年——很多事情都变了。这就把我们带回了……从奇幻的领域回到了历史的领域。克努特（Cnut），他兄弟的死对头，已经死了。
Yeah, I think so, absolutely. But he wants the treasure for a reason. And that's always kind of uppermost and that sounds quite authentic. Yeah, I think so. Absolutely. But he wants the treasure for a reason. And the reason is, you know, the crown matters a lot to him. Now in the 15 years, 15 years that he's been away, because remember he left as a teenager, a lot has changed. And this takes us back to the, away from the realm of fantasy to the realm of history. Cnut, his brother's great rival, is dead.
他已经死了10年，他的北海帝国已经土崩瓦解。英格兰现在由忏悔者爱德华（Edward the Confessor）统治。挪威则由哈拉尔的侄子马格努斯（Magnus）统治，马格努斯是他已故兄弟奥拉夫的私生子。而丹麦则正试图脱离挪威王国。挪威和丹麦之间爆发了一场没完没了的战争。丹麦的那位当权者是一个名叫斯韦恩（Svein）的雅尔（伯爵），他也是克努特的侄子。
He's been dead for 10 years and his North Sea empire has fallen apart. England is now ruled by Edward the Confessor. Norway is ruled by Harold's nephew Magnus, the illegitimate son of his late brother Olaf. And Denmark is sort of trying to break away from the Norwegian kingdom. There's an interminable war between Norway and Denmark. And the guy in Denmark is a Jarl called Svein, who is Knut's nephew.
所以这仍然是一场家族内部的争端，对吧？人们一直觉得耐人寻味的一点是，艾丽丝（Ellisif，即伊丽丝芙），也就是哈拉尔·哈德拉达的妻子，她的一个姐姐嫁给了流亡者爱德华（Edward the Exile），后者是忏悔者爱德华同父异母的兄弟。所以就连英格兰也卷入了这团斯堪的纳维亚通婚同盟的乱麻之中。我的意思是，这真是太奇怪了，不是吗？西奥（Theo）和塔比（Tabby）之前跟我提起过一部叫《维京传奇：英灵神殿》（Vikings: Valhalla）的剧集，我从来没看过，里面就包含了一些这样的情节。
So it's still a family kind of row, really, isn't it? And one of the things that's always thought was intriguing is that Ellis, if so, Harold Hardrada's wife, one of her sisters has married Edward the exile, who is the half brother of Edward the confessor. So even England is part of this snarl of even Scandinavian matrimonial alliances. I mean, it's so odd, isn't it? Theo and Tabby were telling me about a series called Vikings Valhalla, which I've never seen, which has some of this in it.
哦，真的吗？但我认为这本应该是一部预算更大、更令人兴奋的作品。因为我觉得所有这些情节，都让《权力的游戏》看起来像是小打小闹、微不足道的东西。所以，就北方而言，挪威和丹麦一直陷入这场漫长的权力争夺中，马格努斯在挪威，斯韦恩在丹麦。所以，就北方而言，挪威和丹麦一直陷入这场漫长的权力争夺中。马格努斯在挪威，斯韦恩在丹麦。对哈拉尔来说，这既是一个机遇，也是一个威胁。
Oh really? But I think this should be like a much bigger budget and more exciting thing. Cause I think all of this stuff is, this makes Game of Thrones look kind of footling and trivial. So, just on the North, Norway and Denmark have been locked in this long running struggle, Magnus in Norway, Svein in Denmark. So just on the North, Norway and Denmark have been locked in this long running struggle. Magnus in Norway, Svein in Denmark. And for Harald, this offers an opportunity, but also a threat.
如果他能迅速回到斯堪的纳维亚，他就能从中获利，成为第三方势力，并利用这种不确定性渔利。但如果他等得太久，挪威的马格努斯获胜并同时统治了两国，那么他想要立足就会困难得多。所以大概是在1045年初、1044年末吧，具体时间很难说。大约在这个时候，他采取了行动，向北进发。我们确实知道，大约在1045年，他抵达了瑞典一个叫做锡格蒂纳（Sigtuna）的地方，在那里他得到了一个非常糟糕的消息：马格努斯已经占了上风，他去得太晚了。马格努斯已经被加冕为挪威和丹麦的国王，而斯韦恩则
If he can get back to Scandinavia quickly, he can profit from this and become a third player and profit from the uncertainty. But if he waits too long and Magnus of Norway wins and rules both then it'll be much harder for him to get a foothold. So perhaps early 1045, late 1044, hard to say. Around about this time he makes his move and he goes north and we do know that in about 1045 he arrives in Sweden in a place called Sigduna and there he receives very bad news. Magnus has got the upper hand, he's left it too late. Magnus has been crowned king of both Norway and Denmark and Svein has
同意成为他的雅尔，基本上就是他在丹麦的副手。现在马格努斯是个狠角色。他有一半英国血统，这向来是个好兆头。他的母亲是一名英国女奴，他仅在11岁时就成为了挪威国王，但他表现得非常出色。他在赢得支持方面堪称天才。实际上，他是一个极其精明的政治家，他还获得了一个绰号叫“好人马格努斯”（Magnus the Good）。而这部分原因，不仅仅是因为……这并不是因为他很善良。是的。他在政治上很有一套。
agreed to be his Jarl, he's basically his deputy in Denmark. Now Magnus is a serious player. He's half English, always a good sign. His mother was an English slave and he'd become King of Norway at the age of just 11, but he proved really good at it. He was brilliant at winning support. He's actually incredibly skillful politician and he got this nickname, Magnus the Good. And this is in part, not just because it's not because he's kind. Yeah. He's good at politics.
海姆斯金格拉萨迦（Heimskringla Sagas）记载，他能言善辩、果断坚决、品格高尚、极其慷慨，是一位伟大而勇猛的战士。所以哈拉尔虽然带着大笔现金，但他处于劣势。当年秋天（1045年），叔侄俩终于在斯科讷（Skåne）见面——斯科讷当时属于丹麦，如今当然在瑞典南部。萨迦描述了马格努斯带着舰队在那里，他看到一艘来自东方的船只驶来，船头雕刻着镀金的龙首，船身点缀着黄金和珠宝。还有一个身材高大的信使——在这个故事中，乃至在1066年的整体历史中，总是有这些信使，
He was well-spoken and quick to make up his mind, noble in character, most generous, a great and valiant warrior, says the Heimskringler Sagas. So Harold has got all this cash, but he's the underdog. And they finally meet uncle and nephew in Skåne, which was then in Denmark and now is, of course, in southern Sweden, that autumn, 1045. And the sagas describe how Magnus is there with his fleet and he sees this ship coming from the east with gilded dragon's head, covered in gold and jewels. And this huge messenger, in this story, in 1066 generally, there are always these messengers
他们最终证明自己并非泛泛之辈，就像索伦之口（mouth of Sauron）最终证明自己就是索伦本人一样。这个信使走上前对马格努斯说：“你的叔叔哈拉尔会受到欢迎吗？”马格努斯说：“当然欢迎。”接着信使说：“我就是叔叔哈拉尔。”好一个恶作剧。哈拉尔说：“哈喽，侄子。你觉得我们俩怎么瓜分这个王国比较好？”不敢当吧。
who actually turn out not to be, the sort of mouth of Sauron who turn out to be Sauron. This messenger comes and says to Magnus, would your uncle Harald be welcome? And Magnus says, yeah, sure. And then the messenger says, I am uncle Harald. Good fooling. And Harald says, yeah, hello nephew. How would you like to divide the kingdom between us? Not really.
好吧，我们被告知马格努斯对他的叔叔给出了友好的回应，说他会听取诸侯的建议和臣民的愿望。他给出了一个外交辞令般的回答。我刚才说过他在政治上很有一套，于是他们相当友好地分开了，但对哈拉尔来说显而易见的是，马格努斯根本什么都不会分给他。所以哈拉尔派了一个信使去丹麦找那个叫斯韦恩的家伙，说道：“让我们重新挑起那场战争吧。让我们在挪威和丹麦之间重新瓜分地盘。”
Well, we're told Magnus gave his uncle a friendly answer saying he would take the advice of his chieftains and the wishes of his subjects. He gives him a diplomatic answer. I said he was good at politics and they part on quite good terms, but it's I mean, it's pretty obvious to Harold that Magnus is going to give him nothing. So Harold sends a messenger to this bloke Svein in Denmark and says, let's restart that war. Let's divide Norway and Denmark between us.
现在，马格努斯可不想让战争再次爆发，因为挪威并不是一个富裕的国家。你知道的，它没有多少城镇和集市。它也没有特别肥沃的农田。我的意思是，这也是他们卷入整个维京大业的原因之一。但多米尼克，它盛产手持双刃巨斧的魁梧壮汉啊。确实如此，但他们需要发薪水。而且他举步维艰，对挪威国王来说，横征暴敛是个大难题，因为他们确实没有像英格兰那样完善的基础设施。所以马格努斯心想：“我根本无法跟这些黄金竞争，我只是不想打仗。”
Now Magnus, he doesn't fancy the war starting again because Norway is not a rich country. You know, it doesn't have many towns and markets. It doesn't have especially rich farmland. I mean, that's one reason they've got involved in the whole Viking business. But Dominic, it is rich in giant men with double axes. It is, but they require payment. And he struggles, it's a big problem for Norwegian kings to raise tax because they don't really have the same infrastructure as somewhere like England. So Magnus thinks, I can't compete with all this gold, I just don't fancy a war.
所以最终他派人给哈拉尔带了个话，说道：“听着，实际上，如果你愿意分出你的黄金，我就愿意与你共享王国。”哈拉尔心想，好吧，这倒也公平，因为我确实没有多少挪威人脉，而且打这场仗也会带来巨大的麻烦。于是他们召开了这场会议，这是一场非常有趣的、用来分配黄金的会议。哈拉尔大肆炫耀他所有的黄金。他弄来一张巨大的牛皮，把所有的箱子都倒空，堆起了一座座金山。哈拉尔大肆炫耀他所有的黄金。他弄来一张巨大的牛皮，把所有的箱子都倒空，堆起了一座座金山，并大声说道：“为了挣得这些黄金，我曾远赴许多土地，冒了无数风险。”
So eventually he sends a message to Harold and he says, look, actually, I will share the kingdom if you will share your gold. And Harold thinks, well, fair enough, because I don't really have many Norwegian contacts and it would be a massive hassle fighting this war. So they have this meeting, this very entertaining meeting to share the gold. Harold makes a huge display of all the gold. He gets a huge ox hide and he pours all the chests out, massive piles of gold. Harold makes a huge display of all the gold. He gets a huge ox hide and he pours all the chests out, massive piles of gold, and he says very loudly, I have travelled
然后他们打算让手下人把所有的黄金称重并平分，但关键在于，他们俩都得把自己拥有的东西拿出来。接着他说：“侄子，你有什么黄金可以加进来？”马格努斯说：“哦，好吧，我其实已经把所有的钱都花在这些战争上了。我只有一个东西，那就是一个金臂环，就这一个戒指，”说着他把它扔了进去。哈拉尔说道：“作为两个王国的国王，这可真不算多，而且有人会说，这甚至都不是理所当然属于你的。”马格努斯说：“我父亲奥拉夫最后一次见我时把它给了我。”哈拉尔回道：“没错，但那是在他无缘无故从我父亲手里把它抢走之后。”
to many lands and taken many risks in order to earn all this gold. And then they're going to get their men to weigh and divide all the gold equally, but the point is they've both got to put in what they've got. And he says, nephew, what gold have you got to add to all this? And Magnus says, oh well, I've actually spent all my money on these wars. I've got one thing which is a golden arm ring, one ring, and he puts it in. Harold, this is not much for a king of two kingdoms, and some would say it is not rightfully yours. And Magnus says, my father Olaf gave it to me the last time I saw him. True, but only after he took it from my father for no good reason.
空气中弥漫着巨大的紧张气氛。哈拉尔在贬低。实际上他是在贬低他的兄弟奥拉夫，说奥拉夫是从他自己的父亲“播种者西古尔”（Sigurd the Sow）那里夺走它的。所以每个人都为此感到非常焦虑，每个人都说：“哦，这显然长不了。”很显然，在某个时刻，哈拉尔会调转枪头对付马格努斯，反之亦然。好吧，他们中总会有一个人完蛋的，但我们永远不会走到那一步，因为如果你还记得通往1066年之路系列节目的话。就在过去几周里，人们总是会在意料之中、极其方便的时刻突然暴毙。
Massive tension in the air. Harold is dissing. He's dissing Olaf actually, his brother, and saying that Olaf had taken it from his own father Sigurd the sow. So everybody's very anxious about this and everybody says, oh, this clearly is not going to last. Like clearly at some point, Harold is going to turn on Magnus or vice versa. Well, one of them's going to go, but we never get to that point because you remember in the road to 1066 series. So the last couple of weeks, people were always dropping dead on expected convenient moments.
是的。就在他们演员工期结束、极其方便的节点。嗯，在1047年——1047年底，马格努斯在丹麦海岸附近与斯韦恩作战，他做了一个梦，梦见父亲奥拉夫出现在他面前，奥拉夫说：“听着，你有一个选择。你可以活到高寿，但你会犯下一桩将你打入地狱的罪行。或者你现在年轻时就死去，并在来世与我团聚。”而马格努斯，我认为很愚蠢地回答说：“嗯，我选择年轻时死去。我想在来世与你团聚。”你觉得这很愚蠢吗？我认为你根本不知道那罪行的性质是什么。我的意思是，我想了解更多关于那罪行的信息。
Yeah. Convenient points when their acting contracts had come through an end. Well in 1047 end of 1047 Magnus is off the coast of Denmark fighting Svein and he has a dream in which Olaf appears as father and Olaf says, look, you've got a choice. You can live to a ripe old age, but you will commit a crime that will damn you to hell. Or you can die young now and join me in the afterlife. And Magnus, I think foolishly says, well, I'll die young. I'd like to join you in the afterlife. Do you think that's foolish? I think that you don't know what the nature of the crime. I mean, I'd want to know more
但这是发生在什么时候？大约一千年前，如果他当时选了那个，他现在还在地狱里受煎熬，而且毫无获释的希望。这就好像那些针对幼儿的实验一样，你知道的，你是想要现在马上得到一块蛋糕，还是稍后得到两块？我大概会选择现在就要那块蛋糕。我会选择死亡和天堂。好吧，既然如此，你的下场就会和马格努斯完全一样。他醒来后，立刻发起高烧，并在1047年10月25日逝世。而在其中一部萨迦中，有一个非常动人的临终场景——临终场景，睡前场景，
about the crime, I think. But this is happening, what, a thousand years ago and he'd still be in hell now if he'd gone for that with no prospect of release. It's like those experiments they do on toddlers, you know, do you want instant gratification now or you get two cakes later? I'd probably take the cake now. I'd opt for death and heaven. Well, in that case, you would have exactly the same fate as Magnus. He wakes, immediately comes down with a fever and on the 25th of October 1047, he dies. And in one of the sagas, there's a lovely bedtime scene, deathbed scene, bedtime
我的意思是，从某种意义上说这确实算睡前场景。哈拉尔走进去看望马格努斯。“哦，侄子，我看到你快不行了。”而马格努斯说：“放过丹麦吧。我把它留给斯韦恩。让他们和平地生活吧，那些丹麦人。”哈拉尔显然没打算那么做。他现在终于如愿以偿了，
scene, I mean, I suppose it is bedtime in a sense. Harold comes in to see Magnus. Oh, nephew, I see you're dying. And Magnus says, leave Denmark alone. I leave it to Spain. Let them go in peace. The Danes. Harold obviously has no intention of doing that. He's now one,
他成了挪威国王。这正是他一直以来梦寐以求的。这就是他一直以来的全部渴望。经历的所有事情——与巨蛇搏斗、被挖出双眼。你知道吗？你写了这些《时间历险记》的书来激励你的年轻读者追逐他们的梦想，而哈拉尔追逐了他的梦想，现在他成了挪威国王。所以这里面其实有个教训，不是吗？
he's king of Norway. It's all he ever wanted. It's all he ever wanted. Everything has been the fighting the snakes, the gouging out of eyes. And do you know what? You've written these adventures in time books to inspire your young readers to follow their dreams. And Harold has followed his dream and now he's king of Norway. So there's a lesson there isn't there?
但你知道真正的教训是什么吗？这并没有让他感到快乐，因为他担任挪威国王的那段时光其实有点悲伤，我认为，因为那基本上是长达20年、对丹麦人进行的极其无聊的战争，期间什么也没发生。只有不断的劫掠。我猜其中还包含相当多涉及偷牛贼之类的事情。是的。以一种糟糕的天气为背景，烧毁别人的村舍之类的事情。
But you know what the real lesson is? It hasn't made him happy because his time as king of Norway is a little bit sad I think because it's basically 20 years of really boring war against the Danes in which nothing ever happens. Just constant raiding. And I imagine quite a lot of stuff involving cow buyers and that kind of thing. Yeah. Kind of burning people's cottages and stuff in a bad weather.
漫不经心地。是的。天气糟透了。他打了那么久的仗。他有一艘巨大的战舰。我的意思是，这其中最棒的部分就是这艘名叫“大蛇号”（Great Serpent）的战舰。我的意思是，弗洛伊德一定会爱死这个的。奥拉夫·特里格瓦松（Olaf Tryggvason）曾有一艘名为“长蛇号”（Long Serpent）的船，但哈拉尔·哈德拉达和西斯纳（注：此处Sissner原文有误，指代萨迦或相关人物）
In a desultory way. Yeah. Really bad weather. He just fights for so long. He's got a massive warship. I mean, the best thing about it is this warship called the Great Serpent. I mean, Freud would love this. So Olaf Trigversen had had a ship called the long serpent, but Harold Hardrada and Sissner
却有一艘名为“大蛇号”的船。他指挥着这艘船。有一场战役，发生在尼索尔（Nisor）这个地方，那是瑞典西部外海，交战双方是挪威人和丹麦人。挪威人获胜了，但他们都又悲惨又寒冷，双方都蒙受了巨大的损失。没有人能在这场战争中真正获胜。然而，“大蛇号”依然高高竖起，傲然挺立。确实如此，但此时此刻，这里面只透着一种索然无味的沮丧感。
had a ship called the great serpent. And he commands this ship. There's one battle, a battle at a place called Nisor, which is off Western Sweden between the Norwegians and the Danes. The Norwegians win, but they're all just miserable and cold and they both massive losses. No one's ever going to win this war. But the great serpent is still erect and proud. It is, but there's just a sense of joylessness to it at this point.
拥有过一艘名为“大蛇”的船。他指挥着这艘船。有一场战役，发生在尼索尔的一个地方，位于挪威和瑞典西部之间，交战双方是挪威人和丹麦人。挪威人赢了，但他们都痛苦不堪、饥寒交迫，双方都蒙受了巨大的损失。没有人能赢得这场战争。“大蛇”号依然挺立且傲然。确实如此，但此时其中只剩下一丝毫无快乐可言的感觉。
I think it's fair to say. So basically this war has gone on for what 15 years or something. And eventually Harold gives up his ambitions. It's fine. Swain can have Denmark, I've had enough. And all this has been very, very expensive. Swain can have Denmark, I've had enough. And all this has been very, very expensive.
我觉得这样说很公道。所以基本上这场战争持续了大概15年左右。最后哈罗德放弃了他的野心。没关系。斯温可以拥有丹麦，我已经受够了。所有这一切都非常非常昂贵。斯温可以拥有丹麦，我已经受够了。所有这一切都非常非常昂贵。
Now during all this, Harold has clearly been trying to turn Norway into a more centralized, kind of nationalized tax paying kingdom, like, dare I say, England, or to some degree, I guess, in future Denmark. Or, more obviously, I'd have thought, um, Constantinople. Oh, Constantinople, which he's seen. Yeah, but it's going to be, look more like England, I suppose, in the long run, because he's also doing other modernizing things. He tries to develop a national queenage. And although he himself is clearly not a, you know, if he is pious, he's not,
现在在这期间，哈罗德显然一直在试图将挪威变成一个更加集权的、某种国营的纳税王国，就像，我敢说，英国，或者在某种程度上，我想，未来的丹麦。或者，更明显的是，我本以为，嗯，君士坦丁堡。哦，君士坦丁堡，他见过的。是的，但从长远来看，它看起来会更像英国，我想，因为他也在做其他现代化的事情。他试图开发全国性的铸币。虽然他自己显然不是个，你知道的，如果他虔诚的话，他也不是那种，
definitely not a turning the other cheek kind of man. He does encourage Christianity and he brings in priests and monks from Kievan Rus, And of course, you can see why he would do that. He likes the idea of one god, one ruler, one church, state power. He's got his brother, hasn't he? Olaf, who is well on the way to becoming Saint Olaf, who gets enshrined in the great cathedral. And it's interesting, a lot of the kingdoms that are formed at about this point in time have patron saints who are from the
绝对不是那种逆来顺受的人。他确实鼓励基督教，并从基辅罗斯引进神父和修道士，当然，你可以理解他为什么这么做。他喜欢一个上帝、一个统治者、一个教会、国家权力的想法。他有他的兄弟，不是吗？奥拉夫，正走在成为圣奥拉夫的路上，被供奉在大教堂里。有趣的是，大约在这个时候形成的许多王国都有守护神，他们来自
ruling family. Olaf is the paradigmatic example who are just massively, massively important to the regime because they give divine legitimacy to the dynasty. But it's a difficult process in Norway. I mean, Norway, the terrain isn't ideal for trying to impose a kind of a nationalizing regime. There's constant tension with the landowners in the north and in the center of Norway. It's not hanging out with glamorous born empresses, is it? It really is a bit miserable. And also I think there's an element of Harold is becoming possibly a little bit insufferable. Snorri Sturluson, who writes this very admiring biography of him in the saga, says,
统治家族。奥拉夫就是一个典型的例子，他们对政权绝对、绝对至关重要，因为他们为王朝赋予了神圣的合法性。但这在挪威是一个艰难的过程。我的意思是，挪威的地形并不理想，无法强行推行某种国家化政权。与挪威北部和中部地主的紧张关系是持续不断的。这可不是和光鲜亮丽的生来就是女皇的人厮混在一起，对吧？确实有点悲惨。而且我还认为，哈罗德身上有一种成分，可能变得有点令人难以忍受。斯诺里·斯图鲁松在萨迦中为他写了一部非常赞赏的传记，他说道：
King Harald was an absolute monarch, and the more secure he felt on the throne, the more imperious he became, so that hardly anyone dared to differ with him. And the big issue, as always, is money, is tax. He has been trying to raise taxes to pay for this incredibly boring war with the Danes. In 1064, the last full year of the war, the farmers of Norway's uplands basically refused to pay their taxes with tax revolts. So it's like he's turned into Keir Starmer. He's having to deal with angry farmers. Angry farmers, it's the same old story. Well, don't forget, angry farmers had killed his brother. Angry farmers and people in reindeer magic cloaks had killed his father.
国王哈罗德是一个专制君主，他在王位上感到越安全，他就越专横，以至于几乎没有人敢反对他。而最大的问题，一如既往，是金钱，是税收。他一直试图加税来支付这场与丹麦人极其无聊的战争。1064年，也就是战争的最后一个完整年份，挪威高地的农民基本上拒绝纳税并发生了抗税。所以这就好像他变成了基尔·斯塔默。他不得不应对愤怒的农民。愤怒的农民，老一套的故事。好吧，别忘了，愤怒的农民杀死了他的兄弟。愤怒的农民和穿着驯鹿魔法斗篷的人杀死了他的父亲。
We seem a long way now from magic reindeer cloaks. And I have to say, I have to say slightly the poorer for it. Yeah, we are the poorer for it. There's no doubt in my mind. Things have got worse. And this is the point at which they do. So 1065, when the war is over, Harold launched a savage harrying campaign against the uplanders that in some way actually anticipates William of Normandy's harrying camp.
我们现在似乎距离魔法驯鹿斗篷已经很遥远了。我不得不说，我不得不说，因此稍微逊色了一些。是的，我们确实逊色了。这在我心中毫无疑问。事情变得更糟了。这就是他们这么做的时候。所以到1065年，当战争结束时，哈罗德对高地人发起了残酷的清剿行动，这在某种程度上实际上预示了诺曼底的威廉的清剿行。
I mean, this is what there's a definite similarity here that when you have kind of against the uplanders that in some way actually anticipates William of Norman's harrying company. I mean, this is what, there's a definite similarity here that when you have kind of, these are very, very ferocious, merciless monarchs who when they are challenged by provincial, perhaps more small-c conservative interests that are resisting the modernizing efforts of the monarchy, they react with lethal and terrifying force. Snorri Sturluson, the king ordered farmers seized, some of them maimed, others slain, and most of them robbed of everything they owned. The peasants pleaded for mercy, but his verdict came with fire. So again, advice and lesson there from history for Keir Starmer.
我的意思是，这有明显的相似之处，当你面对的是针对高地人的那种情况时，这在某种程度上确实预示了诺曼底的威廉的清剿行动。我的意思是，这就是，这里有一个明显的相似之处，当你拥有这种，这些是非常非常凶猛、残酷的君主，当他们受到地方性的、也许更倾向于小c保守利益的挑战，这些利益在抵抗君主国的现代化努力时，他们会以致命而恐怖的力量做出反应。斯诺里·斯图鲁松说，国王下令逮捕农民，其中一些人被肢解，另一些人被杀害，大多数人被抢光了他们拥有的所有东西。农民们乞求怜悯，但他的裁决伴随着烈火。所以历史再次为基尔·斯塔默提供了建议和教训。
His scald, Theodolf. No scald can find words for the royal vengeance that left the op-lands ravaged and empty. King Harald's deeds will be remembered forever. And exactly that, as you said, Tom, this is the origin of the nickname Hardrada, which at school, I can remember being told it was hard ruler. It's kind of severe, isn't it? That's the translation now. Or even tyrannical or, I mean, some people might say robust. If you admire a strong leader, as I do, you would say robust, like our own greatest ruler in the 1650s. Anyway, that's by the by.
他的桂冠诗人西奥多尔夫写道：没有任何诗人能找到词汇来形容那让高地满目疮痍、空无一人的皇室复仇。国王哈罗德的功绩将永远被铭记。正如你所说的，汤姆，这正是“Hardrada”（哈德拉达）这个绰号的由来，我在学校时，记得被告知它的意思是严厉的统治者。这有点严厉，不是吗？现在翻译成这样。甚至可能是暴君，或者，我的意思是，有些人可能会说坚毅。如果你崇拜一个强有力的领导者，就像我一样，你会说坚毅，就像我们在1650年代最伟大的统治者一样。不管怎样，那都是题外话。
We've got to the end now of 1065. Harold is now probably 50 years old. Ellis Eaf has born him two daughters, but she has pretty much vanished from the sources. We know he has a second wife called Tora, who has had two sons, but we know virtually nothing else about her. I think there's a slight sense of Harold of, I don't know, ambitions unfulfilled or frustration. Yeah. It's a very powerful scene, isn't it?
我们现在来到了1065年的末尾。哈罗德现在可能已经50岁了。伊莉丝·埃夫给他生了两个女儿，但她基本上从史料中消失了。我们知道他有第二个妻子叫托拉，生了两个儿子，但关于她我们几乎一无所知。我觉得哈罗德身上有一种淡淡的感觉，我不知道，是未竟的野心还是沮丧。是的。这是一个非常震撼的场景，不是吗？
And I guess it would require not just a great historian, but a great historian with an incredible command of the English language, fully to evoke the mingled glory and pathos of the scene. And I wonder Dominic, if you can think of such a writer and whether perhaps you have a passage of his prose to hand. Do you know, Tom, it's so, it's extraordinary that you asked that question because by a remarkable coincidence, I can think of such a person. Shall I read it? Yeah, why don't you? Because you, I think you'd give these readings the power and the majesty that they deserve. Yeah. And, and when I finish it, people can try and work at who they think wrote it.
我想这不仅需要一位伟大的历史学家，还需要一位精通英语的伟大历史学家，才能充分唤起这个场景交织的荣耀与悲怆。多米尼克，我想知道你是否能想到这样一位作家，以及你手头是否恰好有他的一段散文。你知道的，汤姆，你问这个问题真是太不可思议了，因为机缘巧合，我确实能想到这样一个人。我要读出来吗？好的，为什么不呢？因为你，我想你会赋予这些朗读它们应有的力量和威严。是的。而且，当我读完它后，人们可以试着猜猜他们认为是谁写的。
Yeah. And maybe order the book. The golden sheen in his hair had long since faded and he could feel a stiffness creeping into his bones. Though Harold would never have admitted it. He seemed a figure out of time, waiting for the end. Sometimes he wondered if he would ever again know the thrill of adventure, the joy of battle. And then one cloudless day, a ship rounded the
是的。也许还会订购这本书。他头发上的金色光泽早已褪去，他能感觉到僵硬正蔓延到他的骨子里。尽管哈罗德绝不会承认这一点。他看起来像是个不合时宜的人物，在等待终结。有时他想知道自己是否还能再次体验到冒险的刺激、战斗的快乐。然后在一个晴空万里的日子里，一艘船绕过了
headland and turned into the fjord. And Dominic, that author is of course yourself, your thrilling book about the Vikings available from all good bookshops. And we know it's a cloudless day. We know this ship has rounded the headland and turned into the fjord. And I think it's fair to say that with that ship and the advent of the year 1066, everything will change, won't it? It will change, Tom.
海角，驶入了峡湾。多米尼克，那位作者当然就是你自己，你关于维京人的惊险书作可在各大优秀书店买到。我们知道这是一个晴空万里的日子。我们知道这艘船绕过了海角，驶入了峡湾。我想可以公正地说，随着那艘船的到来以及1066年的降临，一切都将改变，不是吗？一切都会改变，汤姆。
So to give people a little preview of what is coming, 1066 is upon us. And next week we will begin our climactic series on the epic events of that year. The death in England of Edward the Confessor and the accession of Harold Godwinson. Harold Hardrada invades England and the great showdown at Stanford Bridge. And then the invasion of William of Normandy, and the battle to end all battles at Hastings. And Tom, there's some amazing news, isn't there, for members of the Rest is History Club.
因此，为了让大家先睹为快即将发生的事情，1066年已经到来。下周我们将开始关于那一年史诗般事件的高潮系列节目。英格兰忏悔者爱德华的去世以及哈罗德·戈德温森的即位。哈罗德·哈德拉达入侵英格兰以及斯坦福桥的伟大对决。然后是诺曼底威廉的入侵，以及黑斯廷斯那场终结所有战役的战役。汤姆，“历史的其余部分”俱乐部成员有一个惊人的好消息，不是吗？
Would you like to share that news with them? Yeah, incredible news. You'll never have heard anything like it before, ever, while listening to this podcast. But just to break it to you, if you'll remember, you will hear all four episodes immediately and Dominic, more stunning news that again will come as a total revelation to listeners that if you're not a member of the Rest is History Club, there is a website where you can sign up and that is therestishistory.com. It's what Harald Hardrada would have wanted, isn't it?
你想和他们分享这个好消息吗？是的，难以置信的消息。你在收听这个 podcast 时，绝对从未听过类似的内容。但要透露给你们的是，如果你还记得的话，你将立即听到全部四集，多米尼克，还有一个更震撼的消息，对于听众来说这完全是一个启示：如果你不是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员，有一个网站你可以注册，那就是 therestishistory.com。这正是哈罗德·哈德拉达想要的，对吧？
Yeah, it is. I mean, he would definitely be, he'd be one of the elite Varangian guard of the rest of the History Club. Of that, there is no doubt. All right, on that bombshell, we'll return next time with 1066. Goodbye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，确实如此。我的意思是，他绝对会成为，“历史的其余部分”俱乐部瓦兰吉亚精锐卫队的一员。毫无疑问。好吧，带着这个重磅炸弹，我们下次将带着《1066》回归。再见。拜拜。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。